Good morning.
Seeing that the board members are now present, Brooks, will you please call the roll to establish
a quorum?
Good morning.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Present.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Porter.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Here.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Orozco-Brownson.
Here.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Olken.
Here.
Member McQuillan.
Good morning.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Everyone's present.
Happy New Year.
I hereby call the January 2023 meeting of the State Board of Education to order at 8.31
a.m.
And I'd like us to commence by saluting the flag.
Member Lewis, will you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
Yes.
Salute.
Pledge.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for
which it stands, one nation, under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you so much.
And at this time, I'm going to turn it over to State Superintendent Tony Thurmond.
Good morning, Madam President, members of the board.
It is my honor now to swear in Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond to continue a new four-year term as a board
member on the State Board of Education.
Are you ready to begin?
I am ready.
Very good.
If you would, please raise your right hand and repeat after me.
I, Linda Darling-Hammond.
Do solemnly swear or affirm.
That I will support and defend.
The constitution of the United States.
I'm sorry.
Against all enemies.
Foreign and domestic.
And that I will bare true faith and allegiance.
To the constitution of the United States.
And the constitution of the State of California.
the Constitution of the State of California, that I take this obligation freely, that I
take this obligation freely, without any mental reservation, without any mental reservation,
or purpose of evasion, or purpose of evasion, and that I will well and faithfully, and that
I will well and faithfully discharge the duties, discharge the duties, upon which I'm about
to enter. Upon which I am about to enter. Congratulations. Thank you so much. Much appreciated.
And I will now administer the oath to member Escobedo. And congratulations, Francisco.
Please raise your right hand and repeat after me. I, Francisco Escobedo. You're on mute.
I, Francisco Escobedo. Do solemnly swear. Do solemnly swear. That I will support and
defend. That I will support and defend. The Constitution of the United States. The Constitution
of the United States. Against all enemies foreign and domestic. Against all enemies foreign
and domestic. That I will bear true faith and allegiance. That I will bear true faith
and allegiance. To the Constitution of the United States. To the Constitution of the
United States. And the Constitution of the State of California. And the Constitution
of the State of California. That I take this obligation freely. That I will take this obligation
freely. Without any mental reservation. Without any mental reservation. Or purpose of evasion.
Or purpose of evasion. And that I will well and faithfully discharge. And I will well
and faithfully discharge. The duties upon which I am about to enter. The duties upon
which I am about to enter. Thank you, member Escobedo. Would you like, would you like to
say a few words? Oh surely. It's been a privilege to be part of this board for the last year
and a half. And I look forward to another four years. We're definitely at an exciting
time, you know, as we going through this post pandemic, you know, era. And truly look forward
to working with not only amazing colleagues that I, you know, feel very close to, but
also an amazing staff that has been just a great support. And I know that we collectively
make a significant enhancement in the lives of our teachers and the lives of, you know,
millions of students in California. So it's truly a privilege to serve on this board.
And it is wonderful to have you and all of the other members here. We have a lot of important
work to do. And with that, we'll launch into item one, our state board projects and priorities
item to take up the annual election of officers only. The state board staff recommends that
the SBE take up the annual election of officers and we will hold an election now for the position
of president and vice president for 2023. The bylaws require that the state superintendent
preside over the election of the president. Superintendent, I turn it over to you.
Thank you. Just one moment, please.
Okay, we shall begin. In keeping with article four of the state's board's bylaws, I would
like to call for nominations for the office of president. No member may nominate or second
the nomination for himself or herself. Six votes are necessary to elect an officer and
each officer elected shall serve for one year or until his or her successor is elected.
I will now open the floor for nominations for the office of president. Are there any
nominations? Superintendent Thurman, I'd like to make a nomination, please. I'd like to
nominate. Thank you. Thank you. I'd like to nominate, nominate Linda Darling-Hammond for
the office of president. Thank you, board member Clever Woods. Is there a second to
this nomination? I'd like a second. There is a second. I will now open the floor for
voting now that we have a second. We will also open the roll for any public comment
and for members of the public wishing to provide public comment on this item, you can do so
by calling the telephone number that you now will see on your screen. And so let me
turn to you, Brooks and staff. Are there any individuals requesting to provide public comment?
No, we currently do not have anybody in the queue for public comment. Very good. Thank
you for that. Seeing that there is no public comment, that we have a nomination and a second,
Brooks, would you please call the roll? Member Yoshimoto-Towry? Yes. Member Rodriguez? Yes.
Member Porter? Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson? Enthusiastic, yes. Member Roscoe-Gonzalez?
Yes. Member Olken? Yes. Member McQuillan? Aye. Member Lewis? Yes. Vice president Clever Woods?
Yes. Member Escobedo? Yes. President Darlene Hammond? Yes. Passes unanimously. Congratulations.
Thank you very much. I will reserve my comments until the president's report, but I am truly
grateful for the opportunity to be a part of the great work that we are doing on this board and
working closely with Superintendent Thurman. So I'm pleased to be taking this on for another year.
And I will now open the floor for nominations for the Office of Vice President. Are there any
nominations? Yes. Member Rodriguez? I would like to nominate Member Clever Woods.
Is there a second for that nomination? Member Olken? Thank you. And I guess at this point we
display the public comment slide again in case there are any further public comments as we still
have it up. If anyone wants to make a comment, please call the telephone number and use the
access code provided on the slide that is shown now. And do we have any public comment? No, we do
not. All right. Brooks, can you please call the roll? Member Yoshinomura-Towery? Yes. Member
Rodriguez? Yes. Member Porter? Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson? Smiling beneath my mask, yes.
Member Roscoe Gonzalez? Yes. Member Olken? Yes. Member McQuillan? Yes. Member Lewis? Yes.
Vice President Clever Woods? Yes. Member Escobedo? Yes. Member Darlene Hammond?
And another enthusiastic yes. Congratulations. Congratulations unanimously.
It is my pleasure to announce Cynthia Clever Woods as Vice President for 2023. Congratulations.
And with that auspicious start, do you want to say anything before we get going?
Just how honored I am to be able to serve on the Board and how extremely honored I am to be able
to serve as Vice President for this year. Thank you so very much for the support.
We appreciate all that you are doing and that you will do in the year to come. Now for general
announcements. There is one item on the agenda that has an addendum. Item one, the 2023 State
Board Screening Committee recommendations regarding appointments to the Advisory Commission
on Charter Schools, the California Practitioners Advisory Group, and the Instructional Quality
Commission. In terms of the consent calendars, the proposed waiver consent items are W1 through W5,
and the proposed regular consent items are items 6 through 9. There are no public hearings on this
agenda. And then we have one change in the agenda. We'll reopen item one State Board priorities
shortly to hear reports from the State Superintendent and myself, and we'll reopen item one again
tomorrow to take action on the preliminary report of actions, draft November 2022 meeting minutes
to take up appointments to Advisory Commissions and to report on our liaison assignments.
Members of the public who wish to call in for public comment should view the live stream of
the meeting to know at what time public comment will occur for each item. Public comment may be
provided by dialing the phone number and entering the participant access code,
then following each of the operator's prompts. Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller
queue. The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment.
We'll also ask callers to please turn down the speaker volume of their computers
if they are following the live webcast to avoid an echoing effect. Public comment will be limited
to one minute per speaker. Item 13 is the general public comment item during which members of the
public may provide comment on matters that are not specifically listed on the Board's agenda.
Board members, please mute your microphones when not speaking, keep your cameras on,
except during the scheduled breaks to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout today's
virtual meeting. And for each item on the agenda, there will be an opportunity for Board members
to raise their Zoom hand if they would like to ask a question or make a comment.
And so we'll now reopen item one and turn it over to State Superintendent Tony Thurmond
to provide his report. Superintendent Thurmond. Thank you, Madam President, and congratulations
again to you, President Darlene Hammond, and to Vice President Glover Woods. And I'm honored to
work and serve with you both and to all of the members of the Board. As this is the first time
that we are together in this new year, I want to say Happy New Year to you all. And I'm thinking
back to just the last few days where we celebrated the memory, legacy, and honor of Dr. Martin Luther
King Jr. And it is with that memory that I think of a spirit of hopefulness for our state
and for the state of education, for our nation, and for our world. I think often of the quote
that Dr. King said that everyone can be great because anyone can serve. And in that way,
I thank you all for serving the students and families of California. I'd like to start out
by talking about a wonderful honor that we have starting next month to recognize 256 distinguished
schools in the state of California. These are schools that have demonstrated academic success
in supporting our students, and it has been a tradition in California to celebrate these schools
in February in Disneyland. And this will be the first time that these schools can be in person
since the pandemic. And we certainly invite you to join us in recognizing the distinguished schools
for their great honor and for what their work represents for what we can do for other students
in the state. Some of those students are students who you probably saw were impacted during the
pandemic, and we saw some of those reflections during the presentations about the dashboard
and chronic absenteeism in particular, and seeing that for many students, absenteeism rates have
increased. And because of that, the Department of Education, we've kicked off a series on how
to address chronic absenteeism. And our first of many webinars was held yesterday with a number
of districts sharing best practices for things that they've done before the pandemic, during the
pandemic, and post-pandemic to address the needs of our students. We all know that during the
pandemic, many of our families were food insecure. Our schools serve more than 800 million meals
during the pandemic. We know that there's been a spike in depression and anxiety for many of
our students. I had a chance to do some home visits just a few weeks ago with families
who were chronically absent, and I'd like to thank the folks at Mount Diablo Unified for
allowing me to join their team. And I heard consistently the impacts of the pandemic and
depression, you know, housing insecurity, you name it, all the things that our families are facing.
But we know that they're more than the sum of their circumstances, and there are ways that our
schools can support our families, and the state has provided great resources in our state budget
to do that, not the least of which is a 13% increase in LCFF and other resources that can
be used to support outreach and support. And so we will continue to lift up examples of ways to
support our schools and how to provide engaging instruction and programs that help our students
to accelerate their learning when they have returned to school. We're also busy with our
efforts to support teacher recruitment in our state, and within days we'll be making some
announcements about a new public service announcement campaign to help reach those
who would be interested in becoming a teacher in California, to make them aware of the great
resources that we have, like a $20,000 scholarship, a grant for anyone who wants to become a teacher
or to become a counselor in our schools. Dr. Darling-Hammond and others have worked very
closely to make this happen, and we are actively engaging many who would be interested in serving,
those who are in AmeriCorps programs, those who are working as tutors, those who work as classified
staff, those who work in expanded learning to make sure that they can get connected to all the
resources that exist to become a teacher. And so we'll be making announcements about that in the
days to come. And so we want to continue in a spirit of hopefulness about the things that
we can do to overcome the challenges of the last few years. Today on this agenda you'll hear an
update on the efforts to implement our universal transitional kindergarten program, groundbreaking
that no other state has found a way to guarantee preschool for every four-year-old in our state.
And we look at every aspect of early education and opportunities for our students. Related,
I would just point out that the governor's proposed budget speaks to many items that
many of you have spoken to as priorities, including a proposal to provide an additional
allocation for providing reading coaches and specialists at California schools, $250 million
to build on what was in last year's budget, another proposal for doing that. And as we're
working to implement it again, just the spirit of hopefulness that this is a great opportunity
for California and it builds on a series of learning acceleration webinars
that we have been implementing and many of you have been a part of.
Let's see if we get some technical help. Sounds like the echoing is stopping.
Well, if it's good news, let the good news echo and resound that we have big challenges on the
horizon, but we have the resources and the willpower and the political will to make this
happen for California students. And so with that, I will say that we're prepared to work closely
with this board. I would mention that we have one new staff person to announce and it's someone
that you know. You will see him on a regular basis and you probably have seen him in our legal team.
Bruce Yonahiro has been promoted to fill one of the vacancies of our deputy legal counsel
and you will have the opportunity to work with him and we look forward to making an announcement
for you shortly about our new general counsel in the days to come. This concludes my report.
Thank you so much and thank you, Superintendent Thurman. Congratulations on your inauguration
and re-election. I am honored to serve with you. It's been a pleasure as we tackle so many issues
together and your passion for the children and educators in this state is inspiring and
necessary as we engage in all of this problem solving. So thrilled that you are with us for
another four years as well and I want to just say I appreciate Governor Newsom appointing me to
serve a second term at this critical time when we are facing so many challenges and also making
so much progress as Superintendent Thurman just described. I'm grateful to my colleagues on the
board for all of your ongoing commitment to the path toward a shared vision of schools that serve
the whole child, that empower families, that support educators and that enlist the help of
the whole community in joyful and purposeful learning. As you know, schools are at the heart
of any community and our work to build this whole child framework, one in which students are
supported in their health and well-being as well as their academic studies, is important to
supporting communities in good times and in challenging times like those we've been experiencing.
And as you know, in addition to the challenges of COVID-19 over the last nearly three years now,
the effects of climate change are being felt regularly across the state. These past few weeks,
the intense winter storms were devastating for so many. Lives were lost, homes were lost,
businesses were destroyed. At one point, 429 schools were closed, affecting 185,000 students
across 19 counties. This is just over 3% of the students in California. And most of those campuses
resumed operations fairly quickly, in part due to the great efforts of the staff of many
state agencies, including the Department of Education and the State Board. But the storms
will continue to be felt, and there is one town that's been almost entirely evacuated, and
we will continue to feel the effects of the storms for many, many weeks to come.
And I certainly want to express both empathy and gratitude to the many teachers and principals and
school site staff and parents and students who came together to both weather these storms and
to support these families and children and to focus on safety in our schools. And I also want
to acknowledge that these storm systems, along with the drought and fires that we've been
experiencing, will continue, even as our state leaders and many of our school system leaders are
working proactively to limit challenges to our environment, to move us from fossil fuels to a
clean energy future. We have fleets of electric buses, school buses across the state, and many
schools being renovated. But as we continue to cope with these challenges, it's going to be
important for us, I think, to further develop the work that we began when COVID first arrived
for instructional continuity. And we passed a requirement that districts create instructional
continuity plans and to activate efforts to close the digital divide. Superintendent Thurman and
the governor and the first partner and I all worked very hard on that. And then the legislature
and the federal government finally kind of came online. But we're going to need to build on those
efforts so that we can provide for instructional continuity, find ways to be flexible and fast on
our feet in the use of technologies for learning and when physical presence is disrupted. And this
is true whether it's for an individual student who has to be, who's out because they are unwell or
they're needing to be quarantined or whether it is for an entire school or town as in some of
these instances. Given all that we've done to close the digital divide, we should be seeking
ways to ensure that learning is never short-circuited and that we can use these tools to ensure access to
learning materials and opportunities. So we'll be launching a conversation to explore how we can
enable this kind of support for students and schools. Fortunately, Governor Newsom's budget
that was released last week demonstrates the strong commitment both to further environmental
progress and to further educational progress in the state with the whole child approach that's
so necessary to helping students weather these kinds of events. Despite the revenue being down,
Governor's budget maintains strong fiscal support for schools, continues the programs that we've
already launched to accelerate learning and address troubling disparities by strengthening our
state's commitment to equity. Both the investments in the Proposition 98 Rainy Day Fund and the
allocation of one-time funds over a five to seven-year period as we have seen with community schools
and the recruitment of retention funds for educators will support provide that continuing
support for initiatives. The budget allows for all of these future-minded investments to continue.
A universal preschool as Superintendent Thurman noted, community schools, physical and mental,
health services, after school and summer school programs, intensive tutoring programs,
all of these will be critical to ongoing learning recovery. And we've already begun to see the
effects of these investments in the steeper than normal gains in English language arts and math
that we saw last year for the 740,000 students who took the state smarter balance tests in 2021
and 2022. If we maintain those kinds of steep gains, we will rapidly return to the trajectory,
the positive trajectory that schools have been on. This year's substantial increase in the local
control funding formula, despite that tough fiscal picture overall, provides that solid foundation
for our education system. You know that we've moved from a highly inequitable and inadequate
system of funding before 2013. We were among, if you account for cost of living, we were the last
in the nation in spending. Now we are above the national average and we are beginning to see
the gains and outcomes that accompany those investments. It's also heartening to see an
investment in a literacy roadmap, which will create a cohesive blueprint for improving reading
and writing instruction, bringing together the proven strategies, the evidence-based strategies
that we know of that are articulated in our very lengthy ELA ELD framework and make them
more concrete and applicable with instructional supports for teachers and for the literacy coaches
that superintendent noted we will be expanding. The governor and the administration have focused
on our most vulnerable students through the LCFF equity multiplier. This next development in the
local control funding formula will strengthen equity by supporting schools that serve the
very neediest students in a way that should fortify our resolve to attack disparities for
the betterment of all, and we'll be seeing some accompanying efforts to focus in our
local control accountability plans on being sure that students who are struggling are identified
and their needs being met. In addition to the good news in the budget, we have some good news
here at the state board. This month we welcome three new staff members, chief counsel Kieran Gill,
senior policy director Laura Rodriguez, and assistant policy director Michelle Valdivia.
We have a terrific team. I'm excited we're strengthening our ranks further with these
highly qualified individuals. Kieran comes to us from the attorney general's office,
where she served as a deputy attorney general representing state agencies in the areas of
education, health, and welfare programs and state and federal litigation cases since 2018.
She received the 2021 AG award for excellence in COVID-19 litigation and the 2021 civil division
recognition for competency restoration defense and just last week was recognized for her work
as a member of the education litigation team at the 2022 civil division recognition ceremony.
Laura comes to us from the college board where she was senior director for government relations
and served as an internal content expert on California assessment policy, among other
responsibilities. This will come in very handy as she continues to take responsibility for us
for the assessment CTE and Golden State Pathways assignments. Michelle has been a department of
finance fiscal analyst since 2018. She has deep experience in analyzing, reviewing, and making
recommendations on fiscal affairs and analyzing legislation, preparing memos, and representing
the department of finance before the legislature. Michelle is a former California senate fellow and
AmeriCorps member. She holds a bachelor's degree in social welfare from UC Berkeley.
So welcome to all three of these new staff. And finally, yes, we can take a moment to applaud them
and we will have other moments to appreciate them over the coming year. And then I need to express
my profound appreciation and a bit of bittersweet sadness for state policy director Leila Fai-Mudin
who is moving on to other pursuits at the end of the month. Leila has been a fearless champion for
our students, especially our English learners and students with disabilities. She's been a courageous
voice for more equitable practices in our K-12 system. She has a strong moral compass. She keeps
students at the forefront of all of her work. She reminds us of the importance of student voice in
bringing those that we serve to the decision-making table. She puts equity first and knows that the
future of the state depends on us closing the achievement gaps that we experience.
Leila is a system thinker who connects the dots and she's been very instrumental to our work to
bridge health services and education supports and create the infrastructure needed to make the
child youth behavioral health initiative a success. She's been a stalwart on the state board team,
quick to help colleagues and dig in wherever necessary. And I know that I speak for all of us
and say we'll miss her wit and her problem-solving and her occasional baked goods. And
Brooks, I think you have a certificate for Leila. So we want to join me in a round of applause
and pass the ball to Brooks to award the certificate.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. The certificate has been delivered.
And I'm actually not sure if this is a physical certificate or a virtual certificate at the
moment. It is a physical certificate. We just handed it over. Brooks, let us know
how you want to proceed. I think we just got a big expression of gratitude and thanks.
Looks like something is happening in the boardroom.
Yes.
President Darling-Hammond, can you hear us now? Brooks, I don't know if you are near a microphone
to let us know how you want to proceed. I can hear you now. Okay. We apologize. The boardroom
was muted. It was such an overwhelming response of gratitude for Leila that apparently we knocked
out the mics. So she has received her physical certificate and she gave us a large smile and
double thumbs up and we are all trying to contain our appreciation as well as our sadness
that she's departing. But we are ready for the next item. Thank you. Okay. Thank you.
Thank you. And thank you, Leila, wherever you are. We're going to move on to item two.
Item two is the 2023 United States Senate Youth Program and we're going to be recognizing
California's selected student delegates and alternates. The CDE recommends that we present
the 2023 United States Senate Youth Program and recognize the 2023 delegates and alternates.
And this item will be presented by Dina Fong of the CDE. Dina, please begin.
And we're not hearing anything from the boardroom at the moment, so
just letting you know that the mics need to come on.
Good morning. Can you hear me? Yes, we can. Great. Good morning, President Darling-Hammond,
State Superintendent Thurmond, and honorable board members. I'm Dina Fong, the United States Senate
Youth Coordinator for California and work in our California Department of Education's
Communications Division. I'm honored to be here today to introduce and recognize our 2023 U.S.
Senate Youth students. The U.S. Senate Youth Program is sponsored by the U.S. Senate and funded
and administered by the William Randolph Hearst Foundation. Now in its 61st year, the program
provides an opportunity to selected students to gain an in-depth view of the Senate and the
federal government, as well as provide a foundation for those considering a future in public service
on the local, state, or national level. High school juniors and seniors are nominated by
their principal to apply for this highly competitive merit-based program. To qualify,
students must currently be serving in an elected or appointed leadership position in student
government or a civic or educational organization representing a constituency and serving others
for the entire school year. Our students have gone through a rigorous application process and
were selected based upon their leadership qualities, academic achievement, school and
community involvement, and commitment to public service. The last phase of the program is to
formally present our 2023 U.S. Senate Youth delegates and alternates. These students are
among the best of the best in their school, community, and the state. There is no doubt
that they will succeed in whatever they do and will serve their communities with passion.
Our two delegates will represent California during Washington Week in Washington, D.C.
from March 4th to 11th, where they will participate in a comprehensive public service
leadership and education experience, including hearing from speakers from the three branches
of government and the national media. The delegates will each receive a $10,000 college
scholarship for undergraduate studies with encouragement to study coursework in political
science or history. Now I'd like to take a few minutes to introduce each student and give them
each time to say a few words. Our first delegate is Fiona Liu, a senior at Northwood High School
in Irvine. She has been described as someone with an insatiable thirst for knowledge who is
not afraid to confidently voice her ideas and approaches topics with an open mind and eagerness
to learn. Fiona serves as the policy director of the California High School Democrats. In that
position, she helped launch the organization's inaugural legislative platform by supporting
youth-related bills on behalf of their members and created a legislative advisory committee
to improve the democratic process in supporting bills. Fiona is one of three students from her
school on the Irvine Unified School District Student Advisory Committee, where she advocates
for mental health initiatives and student board member representation. She is a member of the
California Department of Education's Youth Advisory Council as part of the communications
and legislative team and has also interned for Assemblywoman Cotty Petrine Norris. Her community
activities include serving as partnership director for Generation Upboards and as a co-lead and
project manager of a local chapter of Dear Asian Youth, for which she researched a book available
in different Asian languages that show people how to report hate crimes. Fiona wants to explore
majors in comparative studies in race and ethnicity, public policy, and education and
learn about race and its intersection in every aspect of society. She has a passion to support
the underserved and advocate for progressive policies to help marginalized groups stand in
solidarity. Congratulations, Fiona. I'll turn it over to you for a few words.
Thank you so much, Dina, and I just wanted to start off by saying how grateful I am for this
chance to represent California on a national level and learn from some of the most distinguished
people in this country who are and continue to be the trailblazers I look up to in my public service
career. And with this learning opportunity, I'm excited to further my goals in learning how young
people and future generations can engage in both local, state, and federal policy and use this as
a change-making vehicle. I like to do this with an emphasis on racial justice, which I'm very
passionate about, and making systemic change for low-income communities, especially in healthcare
and education access. And along my journey, I like to remind myself what public service means to me,
and that's investing back in the communities that have fostered so much growth within
myself throughout my life and also branching out to other communities to learn and unlearn and
fight for equity and solidarity. So thank you so much.
Thank you, Fiona. Our second delegate is Summer Sun, a senior at Chico High School in Chico.
She has been described as a great example of a humble, quiet leader who leads by modeling hard
work and supportive energies. Positivity radiates whenever she's around, and she naturally inspires
others. Summer is ASB president at her school, where she oversees school-wide functions and
student activities and reports at district board meetings. She has been in student government
every year since ninth grade and has served as class president, ASB secretary, and the school
site council. She is the president of the Students Organized Friendship Alliance Club, whose mission
is to practice social skills with special education students and create a safe space
to celebrate everyone's differences. She founded Read to Rise, a nonprofit global youth reading
program in the local community, Haiti, and China that raises funds to donate books and supplies
for children in poverty and pairs high school students as reading pals for 200 local kids from
economically disadvantaged families. Her passion for volunteerism has earned her the president's
Volunteer Service Gold Award, and as her school's delegate for Girl State, an outstanding citizenship
award for leadership, kindness, and integrity. She plans to major in cultural anthropology with
possible minors in public policy or international relations, followed by a graduate program in law
and government. She is committed to improving the lives of underrepresented groups and minorities.
Congratulations, Summer. Please say a few words.
Hello everyone. I just want to say I'm so happy to be here. Thank you so much for this amazing
opportunity to attend the Senate Youth Program. I just wanted to first thank my teachers, counselor,
principal, and also my superintendent for not just supporting me through the application process,
but all throughout my years of education because I would not be here without them.
I think to me, public service means taking personal experiences and transforming them into
positive impacts. I think that everyone has their own unique story that then allows them to identify
needs in their community and serve in a way that really only they can. I think I honestly just
can't believe that I'm going to be in DC in less than two months. I think this firsthand experience
on how our government works is just truly so special, and most importantly, I'm excited to
learn how to use what I learned to better serve underrepresented groups in my community and my
country. So thank you again for this amazing opportunity. I really cannot express enough how
grateful I am. Thank you, Summer.
If Fiona or Summer should be unable to participate in Washington Week, then one of our alternates
will take their place. Our first alternate is Nathaniel Nate Watts, a senior at Carlsbad
High School in Carlsbad. He has been described as an exceptional human being and a natural leader
committed to service who has the rare qualities of calm, balance, and good humor which allow him
to excel without burning out. Nate serves as a student representative for the Superintendent's
Student Advisory Council at Carlsbad Unified, where he represents student interests and provides
feedback to the district superintendent and the leadership team. He serves as president and captain
of the speech and debate team, vice president of the Indian Culture Club and mock trial,
a delegate of the Model United Nations, and first baseman of the baseball team.
Nate was also recognized as his team's most inspirational player. He mentors younger students
on the debate team as well as elementary students through the Carlsbad Unified Champions,
a district-wide group of students. Nate developed a strong interest in politics and civic engagement
during his time as a Democratic Congressional Campaign Summer Fellow, where he participated in
voter registration, strategizing, organizing town halls, and inspiring youth involvement in politics.
A National Merit semi-finalist and AP scholar with honors, Nate is only one of 22 students worldwide
who has achieved a perfect score on the AP English language exam. He hopes to study political science
and international relations with a focus on the impacts and mitigation of environmental crises.
He wants to dedicate his life to public service to create safer, sustainable communities for
generations to come. Congratulations, Nate. Please say a few words.
Hi, everyone. I just want to say I'm truly grateful for this opportunity.
I want to take this time to thank Ms. Fong, Superintendent Thurmond,
President Hammond, my parents, probably most importantly, as well as everyone back at Carlsbad
Unified. Service to me honestly looks like using opportunities in the present to build a better
future by correcting our mistakes in the past. And in the short term for me, that looks like
continuing to work with my local congressman, Mike Levin, to build a better life for us here
in the 49th District. But then hopefully in the future, in a time past college, I really want to
work on the climate crisis and working on building my generation's solutions to that problem.
So thank you everyone for this opportunity and have a blessed rest of your day.
Thank you, Nate. Our second alternate is Sabrina Brandeis, a senior at Monte Vista High School
in Danville. She is described as a team player who is thoughtful, exhibits grace under pressure,
concerned about the greater good, and hopes to make a difference. Sabrina serves as a youth
commissioner on the Danville Parks and Recreation Commission and represents Danville's teams and the
planning of recreational activities and the management of parks, as well as participating
in decisions that improve Danville's public spaces. She has also served on the Danville Town Council
for five years to represent the team voice in her community through outreach and service projects.
In response to anti-Semitic incidents, she and her sister created a project encouraging students
to discuss intolerance in the community, which led her to become the Stronger Than Hate video
contest national winner. As speech captain of her school's speech and debate team,
she won first place nationally at the Yale Invitational, placed in the top 10 at the
tournament of champions, and placed fourth in California. She was one of two women from
California to represent the state as a senator in the American Legion Auxiliary Girls Nation program
and was chosen by staff as the most outstanding senator for 2022. A national merit semi-finalist,
Sabrina would like to study political science followed by law school and work for social justice
and fight unjust policies and bring justice to those who need it. Congratulations, Sabrina.
Please say a few words. I just wanted to start off by saying I am so grateful to have been given
this opportunity and have been chosen as an alternate for this program. As a child, I made
some of my favorite memories attending the annual Danville Health Workshop. It brought me so much
joy to connect with the other kids in my community every year and of course enjoy the free hot
chocolate. As president of the Danville Youth Council and youth commissioner of the Danville
Parks and Recreation Commission, I've worked to recreate some of the joy and community engagement
of the experiences that I enjoyed so much as a child. To me, public service is about connection.
I take pride in connecting with people in my community about their experiences and what they
see a need for. And as one of California's two delegates to Girls Nation, I formed connections
with girls from all over the country, expanding my worldview with new experiences through
conversations. I hope to continue working to foster connections and engagement in every
community that I'm part of. I want to connect with communities and work to fight unjust policies.
I believe that justice is achieved by first understanding the experiences of another.
And in each connection I make, I hope to add to my understanding of my community and the world.
Thank you so much, Sabrina. Once again, I'd like to again say congratulations to our four
students. You are all doing amazing things in your communities, and I look forward to seeing
what's next. What I've shared today is just a small sampling of their many accomplishments.
We would be here all day if I shared everything they're involved in. I also want to add that all
of the students have been described by their advisor, teacher, principal, or superintendent
as someone who definitely stands out from the rest as evidenced from what you heard today.
I think we can surely feel confident and encourage that these outstanding students are shining
examples of our future and they will go on to do more great things and make a positive difference
in our world. I'll turn this back to President Darling-Hammond and State Superintendent Thurman
and the other board members to offer their congratulations. Thank you very much.
Congratulations to all of you. Am I unmuted now? Yes. Okay. And we really appreciate the level of
commitment to contributing that you expressed and the wisdom that we heard from each of you.
We're going to put the public comment slide up while I pass the ball to Superintendent Thurman
to say a few words so that others can also call in and congratulate you. Superintendent Thurman.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. I just wanted to say congratulations to Fiona and Summer
and Nate and Sabrina for your incredible accomplishments in your local community
and your schools and what you're now doing on behalf of the state of California.
And what you've done already is so impressive in the things that you've laid out for yourselves,
racial justice, environmental justice, public service. It's just so inspiring and so hopeful.
And we know that you're going to do great things. And I suspect that one day we're all going to end
up working for you at some point. And as someone who started in student government, I just want
to encourage you to continue doing this. Look how it's opening doors for you and the communities
that you serve. We couldn't be more proud. Congratulations to you and your families.
And thank you for taking up the call to serve. As I opened with, Dr. King said,
everyone can be great because anyone can serve. You're showing your greatness for you, your
families, your community, and our state. So congratulations. Thank you, Dina, to you and
your team for helping to shepherd this process and to bring forward these incredible leaders.
With that, I'll turn it back to President Darling-Hammond.
Thank you. And plus one to all of that. We do have the public comment slide up and I want to see if
there is any public comment. Anyone who wants to make a comment can call the number shown on the
slide and dial the access code. The operator will let you know when you're online. Is there any
public comment? We do not have anyone in the queue for public comment. All right. And so now I can
open it up to the board members who I know have some congratulations to offer. We're going to
start with Member Porter. Hello, everyone. Fiona, Nate, Sabrina, Summer, congratulations on behalf
of all the students of California. I just want to say thank you for your commitment. Each of you is
working in such niche areas, but something that really resonated with me through all of your
speeches is your emphasis on empathy and community-centered conversations and dialogue,
and I just want to continue to encourage you to use your voice for good, speak up for those who
can't, and congratulations for representing our state at the highest level. Terrific. Thank you.
Member Rodriguez? Thank you. Good morning. I would also like to take this moment to congratulate you
and to let you know how inspired I am with your level of commitment to service and service of
others. Your kindness and compassion is something that really touches me, and your intentional
leadership has filled me with hope this morning. I wish you all the best, and as Superintendent
Thurmond said, we will definitely all be working for you someday. Your leadership is fantastic.
So I look forward to seeing what you do and what you continue to do, because you've already
achieved so much. Member Lewis? Thank you. I think you're going to keep hearing this resonate
throughout all the board members, how impressed we are with what we've heard that you've already
accomplished and the dreams you have for yourselves, for your community. I just love some of the
things that you talked about, equity, solidarity, and giving a voice to the underrepresented.
It is so encouraging just to see the passion that you as young people have and all of the things
that you've done that people at my age never thought about doing when we were in high school.
I mean, you've accomplished so much, and there's no doubt in my mind that you're going to fulfill
all of the dreams and you speak with such passion that I know that you're going to do all of these
great things that you want to do for your community, and as some of you said, for the nation.
So I just appreciate you and congratulations to you for your appointment, and I know that you're
going to do well and represent California well. Congratulations to all of you. Thank you. Member
Lewis? Member Glover-Woods, and then member Olken, and then member Orozco-Gonzalez. Thank you, and I
just will say ditto ditto ditto. I second and third those emotions. All of you young people
are absolutely amazing, and first let me say congratulations to you for being the cream that
has risen to the top in this particular area and being that voice. I'm so excited about what you're
doing in the present and really what you will be doing in the future. Being that voice for the
voiceless in all of those different areas that you've shared with us is something that we need,
and I know your contribution now and your contribution as you continue to go forward
is definitely definitely definitely going to make our world a better place. So again, I say
congratulations to you. Wish you all the best as you go to Washington, whether you're serving there
or serving here, I'm just happy you're serving. Congratulations once again. Thank you so much.
Member Olken? Thank you. I just want to echo again what my colleagues have already said.
I spend my day job is largely in a high school, and I get to see incredible young people every day,
and your leadership, your sense of commitment to others. The thing I think that I love the most
is your belief in the value of every person and wanting to foster conversations across difference
and to show not just how we're different but what we have in common just really resonated
with me, and it stands out, and it's why I think all of us on this board and all educators across
our state do the work we do, and so as we get ready for two days of meeting and thinking about
things at a statewide level, getting back to what it's really about, which is you, is the best
possible start, so I want to thank you for all you've done. Good luck and congratulations,
and thanks for inspiring us this morning. That's already a huge gift that you've given us.
Thank you. Member Roscoe Gonzalez?
I think ditto, right? Exactly what all our members said is I'm so impressed with all that you have
accomplished as a second grade teacher. I want to share your accomplishments with my class
because you're extraordinary role models, and it just gives me so much hope for our future,
and I just think I love the passion of you sharing all your ideas and just your empathy,
kindness, and commitment to what is ahead of, and I'm so excited to see what the future holds for
you because I know it's just not just bright, but it's just illuminating, so adelante to Washington
and good luck, and I know that you will just thrive and shine exemplary, so congratulations.
Thank you, and Member Yoshimoto Tauri?
Thank you. Fiona, Summer, Nathaniel, and Sabrina, I just wanted to say I'm proud not only as an
educator this morning, but also as a mother. You are such an inspiration, and what I notice is that
as you've taken these leadership positions, you expressed today that you're also very much a
learner and very much a listener, and I think that's something that has to be emphasized
because that's going to continue you on your path and creating space for other people's voices,
so I just wanted to say we're all behind you, and be courageous and keep going. Thank you.
Thank you so much. We are so pleased to see you and to send you off on this adventure, as
one of the board members said, you know, you're serving both here and some of you in Washington,
and all of that contribution will make a difference. With that, I think we want to say
congratulations. I don't know if the photos that were to be taken have gotten taken, but hopefully
they have. We'll take one second in case there's any more of that needed, and we will. Thank you
so much for being with us this morning, and we're going to move on now to we're going to conclude
this information item, and thank you, Dina. I also want to say for all that you've done to make this
possible, and move on to item number three, and item three is the California assessment of student
performance and progress and the English language proficiency assessments for California update
on program activities. This is an information item. There is no specific recommended action
at this time, and the item will be presented by Cheryl Cotton and Mal Vang of the CDE. Cheryl,
please begin. Good morning, and happy new year, Superintendent Thurman, President Darling-Hammond,
Vice President Glover-Woods, and board members. Again, my name is Cheryl Cotton. I'm Deputy
Superintendent of our Instruction, Measurement, and Administration branch. With me today to present
these items are Mal Vang, Director of the Assessment Development and Administration Division,
and Tony Alpert, Executive Director of the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium.
The item before you today is an information item.
As we begin a new year, it seems fitting to take a moment and reflect on the great strides
California has made in its statewide assessment system, and to share with you what's on the
horizon. We'll begin today with an update from both me and Dr. Vang on California's commitment
to innovation and assessments that support teaching and learning. We'll then turn it over
to Tony Alpert, who will summarize the recent demonstration of concept study and resulting
deeper learning resources in California, of which California was an integral part.
Two of the goals of California's statewide assessment system are to support teaching and learning
and incorporate technology where appropriate. California transitioned to the California
Assessment of Student Performance and Progress, or CASP, in 2014, and there have been numerous
advancements throughout the past seven years. Over the next several slides, we will highlight
accomplishments that have demonstrated California's commitment to innovation
and assessments that support teaching and learning with a focus on the CASP and the
English Language Proficiency Assessment for California, or LPAC. I would like to begin
with a recent accomplishment regarding California's status in the Federal Assessment Peer Review
process. I am happy to be able to start off the new year with some positive news regarding
the peer review status of the CASP and LPAC summative assessments. Assessment Peer Review
is a process during which the CDE submits documents to the U.S. Department of Education,
or ED, demonstrating that California's assessments meet the federal requirements for validity,
reliability, and fairness established for states by the Every Student Succeeds Act,
or ESSA. As new assessments become operational, the CDE must provide additional evidence for
peer review, covering each assessment that is required under ESSA. Peer review is often
an iterative process, with states submitting additional evidence to meet the requirements
as evidence becomes available. In November, we were pleased to receive notice from the ED
that our Smarter Balanced summative assessments in English Language Arts and Literacy, or ELA,
and mathematics fully met all requirements. This is a significant accomplishment for California,
and we are grateful to staff at CDE, ETS, and the consortium for getting us to this result.
We also received encouraging results from other assessments that were submitted in 2021 and 2022.
Those assessments were the California Alternate Assessment, or CAAs,
for ELA and mathematics, the California Science Test, or CAST, and the summative
English Language Proficiency Assessments for California, for LPAC. Each assessment was rated
as substantially meets peer review requirements, which means that most elements were fulfilled,
but some additional documents are required in order to fully meet all requirements.
In June of 2023, we will submit the additional evidence. In addition, we will be completing our
first submissions for the summative LPAC, summative alternate LPAC, and CAA for science.
The findings thus far in our peer review feedback reflect both the quality of the assessments
themselves as well as the quality of the evidence documents that were provided and presented for
evaluation. The California assessment system, which includes both the CAST and the LPAC,
has been many years in the making, and collectively they reflect California's commitment
to innovation and assessments that support teaching and learning.
And now I will turn it over to Mal Vang to provide some background
on the development and administration of California's assessments. Thank you.
Thank you, Cheryl. Good morning. And I'd like to express my happy New Year greetings to you.
And congratulations, Superintendent Thurmond. I want it on your re-election. I am happy to be
a part of this organization. And just a couple other words of congratulations to our
President Darling-Hammond and Vice President Glover-Words on your
new roles or continuing in your new roles. As Cheryl mentioned, I'm Mal Vang. I'm the Director
for the Assessment Development and Administration Division at the California Department of Education.
And I look forward to working with, continuing to work with all of you.
With our next slide, I would like to just give a little background on our transition as Cheryl
set the stage that as the State Board of Education has adopted new standards in our state,
for example, we continue to develop academic assessments to meet these challenging standards.
And after the State Board's adoption of the Common Core State Standards in English Language, Arts,
and Literacy and Mathematics in 2010, California joined the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium
in that academic year of 2010-2011 with the understanding that this would bring immense
benefit when we are joined and being a part of a multi-state consortium. So by joining the
Smarter Balanced Consortium, we offered, we can offer at that time our nearly 300,000 educators
in our state a comprehensive assessment system that reached far beyond just the end of year
summative assessments and focused on supporting teaching and learning and expanding the system
to also include interim assessments and formative assessment resources that we never had before.
And they're intended to be used by educators in a manner that best meets the needs of their students.
So California's previous assessment system, Prior to CAFS, was the standardized testing and
reporting program, or STAR as many of you might remember, that came to an end in 2014. And in 2015,
California officially transitioned to computer-based testing with the first operational
administration of the Smarter Balanced summative assessments for English Language, Arts, and
Mathematics. And these assessments were our first use of computer-adapted testing in statewide
assessments, meaning that students receive items customized to match their level of knowledge,
resulting in more precise measures of student performance. And in addition, these assessments
were the state's first use of innovative assessment types such as technology-enhanced items like drag
and drop and graphing, selected response, constructed response, including performance tasks as well.
And then in 2017-18, the state's previous English Language development assessment program, which was
called the California English Language Development Test, or SALT, was replaced by the LPAC. And that
began with a paper-pencil assessment and transitioned to online as well. So while the CDE offers a
variety of CASP and LPAC-related professional learning opportunities each year, in 2019-20,
the CDE hosted the inaugural California Assessment Conference, and this change provided an opportunity
for local educational agency staff to access through one event key elements of assessment-related
trainings offered by the CDE and hear directly from our colleagues or their colleagues throughout
the state about how they are implementing parts of the state assessment system locally.
And this mix of professional learning opportunities and sharing of local best practices was well
received and became an annual event hosted by the CDE through its contract with the
Sacramento County Office of Education. In terms of developing our assessments, to get to that first
operational administration, offering a quick little timeline for the CASP and the LPAC. Again,
as each set of standards were adopted, the CDE worked with our contractor ETS to develop and
administer assessments that are aligned to these standards. And from the time that a set of standards
is adopted, it can take several years until the assessments can be administered operationally.
So by operationally, I mean the point at which the results from the assessment can be
usable for the purpose of making determinations based on a score. And prior to the operational
administration, a host of activities must occur from the development of a high-level test design
and blueprint to item development, pilot testing, and field testing.
The first CASP assessments that were administered operationally were the Smarter Balanced summative
assessments. And in that same year, Smarter Balanced also launched the first set of interim
assessments operationally, and then the Digital Library of Formative Assessment tools. And although
being a member of the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium, California had access to the English
Language Arts and Mathematics assessments, we needed to design and develop and administer
the science test, the alternate assessments for English Math and Science, as well as the English
Language Proficiency assessments. And many California teachers participated, and their
contributions were instrumental in the development of all of our statewide assessments. In each of
these years, in 2015-16, was the first operational administration of our alternate assessments for
English Language Arts and Mathematics. And then in 2017-18, we had the through the 21st with
initial and summative ALPAC assessments. They began with paper format and transitioned to
online. And then in 2018-19 was the first time we had the California science test and the
Spanish assessment operationally. And this past year, in 2021-22, was when we finally
had the California alternate assessment for science administered operationally.
And the first operational administration of our summative alternate ALPAC occurred in the 2021
year. And the first operational administration of the initial ALPAC is occurring this year in
2022-23. So the next assessment on the horizon to be expanded is the expanded California
assessment, Spanish assessment, which beginning in 2024-25, we will include the speaking and
full right. And with that, we continue to study in terms of innovations in progress. We continue
to study and consider innovations to California's assessment system. And in 2021-22, Smarter Balance
conducted a demonstration of concept study to begin examining how performance tasks can support
learning throughout the year. Shortly, Tony Albre will be providing more information on that study.
But the SBE, CDE, and ETS are laying the foundation by connecting with
state assessment practitioners and national experts for the development of the CAST
innovations concept study, paper, excuse me, that will be brought before the board later this year.
And ETS and CDE are also working toward implementing the CAST and ALPAC interim assessments
for the 23-24 school year. And implementing these assessments involve making many changes
to multiple systems, including but not limited to our test delivery system, teacher hand scoring
system, data entry interface, and the California educator reporting system. So with that, highlighting
these innovations that are still in progress, I will turn this presentation over to Tony Albre,
who will provide an overview of the recent demonstration of concept study and a group
of resources that resulted from the study called our integrated deeper learning resources.
And Tony will be presenting virtually. So Tony, I'm going to hand it over to you.
Thank you, Mao. And thank you, Cheryl, for the overview. It's, I think, really powerful
to have this conversation about innovation with the understanding that California is taking these
steps from a position of strength with a strong description of priorities and investment over
a decade now to transition to a more powerful system that doesn't just do an end of year check
but supports instruction throughout the year. And toward that end, then, consistent with what Mao
described, we collaborated with President, State Board President Linda Darling-Hammond
and CDE and some other partners to really investigate what can we do more,
how can we help more. So next slide, please.
In addition to the California Department and the State Board, we also included some
partnerships, collaboration with the new teacher center, who helped us address the professional
learning needs of educators as we consider both changes to the system, to a system and
maintenance to the system. So there's managing change, and then there's supporting implementation,
which really depends a lot on the information that we're able to provide to teachers
in advance and during the implementation of a system. And then WestEd supported our work
by helping develop some of the teacher resources that were included in the demonstration.
Next slide.
As Mao described, the primary purpose of this was to investigate how can the Smarter Balanced
summative assessment better support teaching and learning. And it was a grounding, a founding
principle for the assessment system. And we have tools for teachers and the interim assessments
that more clearly support teachers as they improve their practice and support the individual
needs of their students. But the summative assessment, that relationship isn't particularly
clear during the year. It's more clear how it can be used after the year is over, but we wanted to
push a little bit further. And in part, the state board's request is we think about how we reduce
the footprint of the end of the year test while we spread that out a little bit
so that districts might have more flexibility in providing data that supports a summative assessment
and consistent data statewide, but also doesn't concentrate it so much in a single point in time
to make it all work a little bit easier. Next slide. So as a reminder or an introduction,
the Smarter Balanced theory of action that we developed well over a decade ago now, which is
hard to believe, it's pretty basic. And that is the premise that the way we support
improvements in teaching and learning is that we help teachers by providing resources that they need.
And the Smarter Balanced assessment was then defined with three major components, the summative
assessment, the interim assessment, and then tools for teachers, which supports that formative
assessment process that's so essential to changing practice in real time to meet students' real time
needs. So the premise is that if you have the standards and you provide the resources that are
helpful to improve teaching, then students will learn more and they will leave high school with
choices rather than having the choices defined for them based on their opportunities or their
background. And so really making available the full array of opportunities that students should have
based on providing them high quality learning opportunities. Next slide.
So more specifically in terms of this particular slice of what is a much larger issue about
improving teaching and learning, we asked three basic questions. The first that I
touched on is can we reduce the footprint of the summative assessment at the end of the year
by giving more flexibility to administer the performance task earlier in the year
based on the needs of the district or school, the needs of the teacher, the needs of the student,
how that might fit better. The next question was can we provide resources that help teachers better
understand and better address the higher order thinking skills that the performance test measure
with the goal not that students do better on the test, but the goal that teaching is improved and
that students have access to these skills and can apply their skills during the year so that they
are more successful in retaining them and as a consequence of that demonstrating it. But really
the focus was on that teaching and learning process. And then the essential question is
what supports do educators need to be able to engage in these tasks to improve their
teaching of higher order thinking skills and adjust to their students' needs.
Next. So as a level setting opportunity, I wanted to describe the Smarter Balanced
Performance Task and really, oh, Linda, a huge thank you for her continuing support
in helping to make available this unique system. It was a hard fought change 10 years ago and still
is unique in that the Smarter Balanced Performance Tasks are designed to provide students with that
opportunity to demonstrate their higher order thinking skills and it was designed in a way to
be consistent with how K-12 educators and higher ed faculty provide instruction and the activities
and the demonstration of skills that they expect in authentic settings so that when we're measuring
these knowledge and skills, it's measuring in a fashion that's consistent with the type of
application that students need to do in their post-secondary objectives. And so we asked students
to explore and analyze really real world type settings. So in the context of English language
arts, they're asked to review three informational articles that are complex and then they're asked
to write an analytical essay that utilizes evidence from those informational articles to
either provide a rhetorical or argumentative essay as the case or narrative as appropriate
for the grade. And for mathematics, the performance task is unique in that it asks students to address
a real world problem from multiple angles and then not only to analyze the problem,
but also communicate their approach to solving the problem and that's essential in business
environments as well as to be successful in more collaborative environments in post-secondary
education and it's a very difficult concept to otherwise measure on a summative assessment.
Next slide.
So as we're thinking about using this performance test as a starting point
for measuring these higher order thinking skills, sometimes called 21st century skills,
sometimes called practices or operations, lots of different labels, but those are critical
thinking skills that we value that can be generalized across a variety of topics.
We implemented this study in fall of 2021 and it was difficult to gain participation
in part because schools and districts were still recovering from the pandemic.
And similarly, educator availability was limited during the school day in part because substitute
teachers weren't available, students' needs were much greater, teachers were absent in and of
themselves due to illness or other taking care of family members. So with that context, it was
just want to help folks understand that this was possibly the most difficult time
ever to initiate a study, especially a study that addressed higher order thinking skills
and not just the minimum level of content that might otherwise be addressed in a different study.
We are very appreciative that two California school districts participated
with 63 educators. So in the grand scheme of things, it's a wonderful contribution for these
educators and I can't express my gratitude enough. We want to be limited though in the degree to
which we apply the results of this and generalize the results of this study, but it is certainly a
good start to the conversation. As part of their engagement, educators attended four
virtual professional development sessions and those really were intended to help teachers
understand the content standards associated with the critical thinking skills that we value
so highly and to support their identification and their adoption and incorporation of instructional
strategies and formative assessment strategies that helps students better learn those higher
order thinking skills. As part of this, they implemented a resource that we now call the
integrated deeper learning resource that Mao mentioned. It's currently available in tools
for teachers as a support for all educators and that was designed to directly walk teachers through
some lessons and activities that help address the higher order thinking skills
consistent with the teacher's instructional scope and sequence.
And then they administered interim assessment performance tasks and most critically the
professional learning session addressed the scoring of that task. So applying the smart balance
rubric to the student work, level setting on that performance expectation that we collectively agree
on and then identifying those features of the text that are exemplars of both the requisite
level of performance that we're seeking but also the indications that the student isn't
performing well so that teachers have a better understanding of the features of the student's
response that either are indicative of proficiency or indicative of not yet proficient.
And then as part of the process the educators participated in surveys and focus groups
wherein they described their experience in the demonstration of concept. Next slide.
So a little bit more about the performance task design. It's as we think about how teachers
utilize this resource. It was based on an evidence-centered design approach where we asked
what are the types of evidence that students should provide in support of a claim that they
are proficient. It was based on a foundation of universal design and accessibility and we can
talk a little bit more about all the features that are available to students both as
universal tools but also as designated supports or accommodations. And as I described it was
vetted well throughout the design process with the educators who would rely on these data
to help ensure that they represent the content that they are otherwise asking students to learn.
We did engage in cognitive labs with the students to make sure that the evidence that we think we
were collecting or we thought we were collecting is in fact representative of what the student's
cognitive process and the application of their knowledge described. And then we piloted the task
to refine them based on the data. Next slide. So one of the founding principles of Smarter Balanced
is that we incorporate the educators, the people that need to use the system into the design
and the development of the system. And so educators help write and review these performance
tasks both in terms of content alignment as well as trying to minimize any bias and be attentive
to sensitive topics that might prevent students from being able to engage in the test and
demonstrate their knowledge and skills. For ELA we also engage with educators to select the passages
that are the founding body of evidence for the students writing. And in math because ELA tests
tend to be pretty consistent in terms of their difficulty. But math we have to have a unique
rubric for each performance task. We engage in some small scale trials which I think Linda has
referred to as smoke testing to make sure that they work out and have a good chance of successfully
being field tested. The final step is field testing and then we go through the rigorous
psychometric evaluation to make sure that these tasks are as free of bias as possible and
describe students' knowledge and skills in a consistent way across years. Next slide.
So as a grounding as we think about what are critical thinking skills, I'm not going to go
into detail about this, but I wanted to make sure that we're aware of some of the different
tasks that are necessary to describe the full body of knowledge incorporated into California's
content standards, but to differentiate what are otherwise considered more foundational skills or
lower level skills for lack of a better term as compared to these higher order thinking skills.
And we can for ELA, we use a taxonomy described by Webb where level one is about recall,
level two incorporates comprehension and synthesis within a text, level three gets more
at analytical and synthesis across multiple texts. So next slide.
And then level four, which is very difficult to measure on a single point in time assessment
is about that more extended engagement in understanding content and applying
problem solving thinking skills and other related knowledge and skills into an artifact or some
other demonstration of learning. So the performance task gets a little at level four. It's notable
that Webb describes that extended time is necessary probably, but not sufficient to describe
an extended activity given that you could have extended incorporation of recall as an example,
but that wouldn't get at this notion of a long-term engagement in a complex application of skill.
But it's principally a level three type activity. We can go to the next slide.
And so when we're talking about math, we're incorporating some of the cognitive processes
that students engage in as they solve problems, as well as the difficulty of or the type of task
that they're using to demonstrate. And so we incorporated a combination of cognitive
rigor matrix with depth of knowledge. And so similar to ELA, but slightly different is that
DOK is about following simple procedures, calculating operational use of formula.
DOK2 is about selecting the appropriate procedure and tools amidst a variety of
opportunities to solve a problem. And level three is designing an approach to solving a problem for
a specific research question, as well as using reasoning and planning and providing supporting
evidence for the choices and the solution. And then level four is that more extended approach
to a larger holistic solution to a complex problem. Next slide. So as we think then about
how do we prepare students, how do we help teachers actually prepare their students
to learn these really important skills and not just focus on the lower level skills of recall
or operations, but fully address and embrace the application of their skills in terms of reasoning
and communication and organization and design. We provided a resource that we now call the
integrated deep learning resources. Next slide. And originally we named it the performance task
support activity, but I think we got some early feedback from this esteemed body that it looked
like we were trying to prepare students for success on the performance task. And that was
not the case. And so to at least address that initial misunderstanding, we renamed it to better
clarify that these are resources that are designed to support the instruction process,
which we believe would help students perform better on an assessment, but that is not the
principal goal. And it incorporates as part of the approach, it incorporates an understanding
or description of the content standards, walks teachers through potential student learning goals
that the teacher will address, provides scaffolding for the teacher to help support students as they
engage in an activity, as well as provide some description of plausible student responses
to specific activities that the educator can provide to elicit students' demonstrations of
higher order thinking skills. Next slide. Embedded in the approach to the embedded deeper learning
resources is the utilization of a cognitive framework called ways of knowing. And we grounded
our approach in research, and there's a paper that we published authored by Paulina Bernacchi
that kind of consolidates all of the available information about how ways of knowing can be a
powerful resource, a powerful approach to help instruction. And I'm by no means an expert on this,
but briefly, using ways of knowing during instruction is a means of accessing these more
complicated concepts, but in a way that draws on students' backgrounds, knowledge and experience
to help them make relevant these skills and applying them in a way that is engaging and
meaningful for them so that they can truly learn the skills in a manner that's consistent with
how they see the world. Which is, it's not about changing the standard, it's about changing the
context during instruction so that it's relevant and that students can utilize their assets
during instruction to be successful. Next slide.
Similar grounding is the formative assessment process that we utilize. There are four components
to our process. We support teachers as they clarify what is going to be learned, how they elicit
information from students about what they have learned and the degree to which they can
demonstrate their knowledge and skills, support teachers as they interpret their knowledge and
support teachers as they interpret that evidence, and then the what next, how do they act on it.
These elements or attributes of the formative assessment process are incorporated into
the deeper learning resource, both to support the teacher in the application of that resource,
but also to model how they might apply a similar formative assessment process in other circumstances.
Next slide. So the professional learning that educators participated in and a huge thank you
and acknowledgement of the NTC's work, new teachers work, new teacher centers work on this product.
Next slide. The goals were to deepen teachers understanding of the cognitive process and
cognitive demands that students need to engage in in order to provide evidence of their higher
order thinking skills and also identify and adopt key instructional practices that they can utilize
to help students learn and be proficient and demonstrate those skills. Next slide.
There were four sessions. These are the one started with the grounding in the standards,
then it was about helping students apply their knowledge in a related to those standards in a
context different than the performance task, but related to the types of evidence that students
would be providing in a performance task, then engaging in that scoring process where teachers
apply the rubric and look at student work and discuss the exemplars of proficiency so that they
can better apply that in their own instructional context and then how to utilize that data to
support their instructional plan. Next slide. As part of the process, there were three steps.
They reviewed a performance task as an exemplar of the demonstrations of skill, the elicitations
that would be required. Teachers engaged in a reflection of what are the types of instruction
that need to occur, what are the instructional events that need to occur so that students can
actually master these skills, and then how can they apply that in their classroom practice
to better support their students. Next slide.
Some considerations that teachers incorporated were looking at the tasks or the
texts and asking do they request students to engage in tasks, texts that are similarly complex
or as they consider the performance that they're hoping students will have, and then other types
of questions that they ask students to answer, are they in fact evidence-based, are they text-based,
or are they drawing on information that isn't necessarily exclusively available from the text,
and then do their instructional activities, do they get at those higher order thinking
skills around synthesis, analysis, and holistic approaches to problems. Next slide.
Teachers were asked as an example to identify the specific skills that students would need in
order to reach a proficient level on the rubric or on the overall on the task related to higher
order thinking skills, and then they engaged in an analysis of their scope and sequence to identify
when they might administer this embedded deep learning resource that starts to get at activities
that directly relate to the higher order thinking skills, and when they might also administer a
summative assessment interim performance task to consistently and systematically understand
how well students have learned those skills. Next slide.
As an outcome then of the professional learning events we created in collaboration with new
teacher centers some deeper learning educator modules that are also now available in tools
for teachers that address these professional learning events that I described earlier. Next slide.
So some results, and with the caveat that this is a very small sample, it was a unique time,
hopefully a unique time in our history, we did get some really positive feedback, and that is
70 percent of the responses, and it's there were some repeated responses in there, but we can
for the purpose of this conversation we can say 70 percent of teachers felt that the instructional
resources and performance tasks were useful to inform lesson planning, which is incredibly
powerful affirmation of the design of the performance tasks to support instructional
planning, and then 77 percent felt confident that they could use the task the data from the task to
actually inform instructional decision. So being able to use the tasks as a signal for instruction,
which was always a hope that we have, but now to get that validation that it is it is feasible,
the design works, that teachers can use these tasks as signals for the type of instructional
activities that they need students to engage in to be successful, to acquire these knowledge and
skills, and then that the data then can be useful to actually adjust and fine-tune their instruction
are wonderful affirmations. Next slide.
Not surprising to us, but continuing affirmation that teachers most value those scoring events
where they look at the rubric, they look at student work, they discuss
which exemplars are indicative of proficiency and the demonstrations of student work that are
indicative of gaps or needs needing for improvement. The other sessions were highly rated, but
by far scoring, the sessions regarding scoring were most valuable. Next slide.
Some quotes about from the teachers that help give some more flavor, some context to their experience.
The takeaway for the for some teachers was about how they were able to use this information to
engage with students around the high order thinking skills and help fine-tune their conversations about
how students need to change their or what students need to do differently in order to
improve their performance and have teachers consider that as well
regarding the tasks that they're asking students to engage in and are they really supporting them
sufficiently at the depth that students require. Next slide.
The rubric-based approach and as a part of a planning of instruction is incredibly powerful
and an affirmation that at least one teacher is going to shift her focus
and better incorporating informational tasks into her instructions so that students can
build up their repertoire in that area. Next slide.
Some issues and there are many. This is about continuous improvement which we've been
engaged in over the past decade or so but the PTSAs are hard to administer in a single class
period. There's a lot a lot that's going into those and so we tried to make it as efficient
as possible and fit within a single class period and we weren't entirely successful so we'll
revisit what does that structure look like so that it can be more easily administered and support
teachers better and the professional learning we heard there were some teachers that knew this
material and felt like it was redundant with what they already know and other teachers who
are newer teachers really valued the information so really thinking about differentiation
of content based on the teacher's experience is going to be critical moving forward. Next slide.
The notion that teachers are going to be able to incorporate these resources
into their instruction requires some significant advanced planning both at the state level but also
within the LEA and the classroom depending on the flexibility that teachers have regarding
their instructional scope and sequence but to the extent that things drop down from the sky
after they already have their plan laid out is a recipe for failure and so thinking about how can
these processes be established to allow multiple people at every level of the educational enterprise
better understand the process and better plan in advance is critical to success. Next slide.
Teachers expressed concern about although this demonstration utilizes interim performance tasks
the angst the the attention that we need to be brought into the process to better incorporate
to do something similar with the summative performance task requires that additional level
of planning to make sure that districts support the schools and that there's a consistent
understanding of the timing of the both instructional events and the assessment events. Next slide.
So next steps we're going to continue to discuss possible models for adding flexibility into the
summative assessment with a focus on these higher order thinking skills. We're going to vet different
models with technical experts and and of course incorporate educators because we need to make sure
that the system works for them and works for their students and then we'll design another pilot
that supports California's priorities and really provides a clear value proposition to districts
regarding how this will help their teachers help their students so that we can encourage
participation and and make make really valuable changes. So that is our slide. Thank you. At this
point it'd be great. Thank you so much. Please put up the public comments slide. Thank you.
So that we can receive any public comments. Members of the public who wish to provide comments
should do so by calling the telephone number that will be on the slide when it goes up
and dialing the access code provided on that slide. There we go. And while we're waiting I
want to ask member Orozco-Gonzalez if she has any initial comments before me. We'll take any
clarifying questions go to public comment and then come back for board discussion.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez. Yes. Well yeah I lots of information. I think I'm most interested in
to see how the new instructional professional resources to support integrated deeper learning
will help support classroom teachers to elevate classroom learning. The two sets of resources for
educators are now available and I'd like to see how those are incorporated in the classroom.
I think the integrated deeper learning resources the instructional resources support educators
instruction in the full range of higher order thinking skills is going to be key. I think it's
going to be all the supports that are in currently. I found that some of the feedback that was given
by teachers would be resonated also by me which is section sessions regarding scoring was found
most beneficial. I know that when I participated in these sessions just looking at student samples
and having that collaborative conversation with my colleagues has been key to seeing how we how we
evaluate and we follow the rubric. So I think that that's going to continue to be a good benefit for
teachers also the differentiation of professional learning that needs to be tailored to the
different teacher needs. I'm a proficient educator when it comes to assessments and I know when I sit
in my grade level meetings and at the district level and sometimes even at the statewide when
we have workshops that invite teachers throughout the state it's always key to have that differentiation
because there are multiple levels to where teachers are at and I think that that will also
help elevate student learning and the more I can say for the next steps is yes incorporate as many
educators at different levels to give feedback to participate in these professional learning
opportunities because the more that we dive in as educators and we're provided with those opportunities
I think that the students will have a better opportunity to succeeding in these performance
tasks. I'm excited to see the deeper level educator modules I think that these professional
learning resources will definitely provide the professional learning community an opportunity
to dive in and have the opportunity to to present it to their local agencies to just down to nuclear
to the classroom where you have those grade level meetings where teachers plan and collaborate it's
that tailoring that time that they spend looking at these assessments that will really
meet the needs of our students so thank you for all the information going forward
incorporate as many educators as you can. Thank you. Thank you so much. I'll just note that
Smarter Balanced has been on the forefront of trying to really move towards assessment
of for and as learning in a variety of ways so a lot of those were detailed it's exciting to see
some potential next steps in doing that. Tony mentioned that I was a strong advocate for
performance tasks as part of assessment when Smarter Balanced was founded I was once on the
technical advisory board for the assessment and the 10 or so states that are involved in Smarter
Balanced have been those that have really wanted to lift up the higher order thinking skills and
21st century skills that we all started talking about in the 1990s but are still trying to get to
in our curriculum instruction and assessment system so the idea for this
demonstration of concept really began during the pandemic as we were trying to figure out
how to make it possible for people to engage in assessment in under the challenging conditions
but there are now a number of states that are looking at ways across subject areas to
make assessment much more part of the instructional process during the school year
not just at the end of the year so it will be interesting to see what is plausible
and productive and supportive of the teaching and learning process as member
Oresco Gonzalez says it's really to support educators and students in the learning process
that we would undertake any of the potential moves that would evolve from
this kind of exploration so thanks to Tony for leading it I want to let board members if you
have clarifying questions about specifics get those on the table now hold the bigger discussion
until after we have public comment so with that are there any clarifying questions at this moment
before we go to public comment yes member Lewis
just one question you know in the report because of the range of readiness that the teachers
reported during that professional learning you know some found the information you know regarding
the performance tasks that information kind of difficult and some felt like it was repetitive
is there any timeline yet for the next steps to be able to reach more educators and prepare
Tony do you have a response to that yes President Darling-Hammond and member Lewis thank you for
the question so I think some additional context that's really critical to as a foundation is that
California is unique in the volume of professional learning events that it
provides on a on an annual basis and there's I think 12 different workshops and and 24 or
and 12 different settings across the state for each workshop so this demonstration concept is
a small slice of what otherwise is a large body of professional learning that CDE provides
we're not quite sure how to fine tune yet the professional learning because we don't yet know
what the focus will be for the next pilot but it's more than likely going to incorporate the
scoring event as as a principal focus and then we'll consider what other knowledge and skills
what other adult learning goals we need to address but certainly giving some opportunities
for people to step in later into the session if they already have the grounding but to engage for
instance if they already know the rubric they don't need to learn about the rubric but then
to engage in the scoring event where that collaborative review of student work and that
that wonderful argument that can occur about those threshold demonstrations of performance
they might be able to engage in that successfully and have that be facilitated by an expert
but we'll continue to consider what can we provide in addition to what California already provides
as we move forward thank you any other clarifying questions at this moment
all right let's go ahead to public comment and then we can come back and have a more complete
discussion if anyone wants to call in for public comment please dial the number
showed on the slide and punch in the access code comments are limited to one minute do we have any
public comment yes we do it looks like we have a couple callers in the queue i will open the
phone line now terrific thank you good morning please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now
Peter Ahern California Association of Science Educators speaking on behalf of the Coalition
of Science Educators and Organizations we are grateful to CDE for their work on getting CAS
to meet the federal requirements we are excited about the work on the CAS assessment innovations
and the interim assessments and look forward to following the progress and supporting the work
we understand from CDE's timeline that scientists plan to be on the dashboard in 2024
we are disappointed by this timeline since 2023 is the year that we have two years of data
and our understanding has been that science would be on the dashboard once two years of valid and
reliable data were available we ask again that there be at least be a placeholder in this year's
dashboard to signal to districts that they need to invest in science education many districts have
not yet invested in NGSS curriculum and professional learning and are not likely to do so until science
is included on the main dashboard having a strong science education for all students is vital to
provide equitable access to STEM career pathways it is also critical that California has a science
literate workforce and citizenry thank you thank you next caller please state your name and
affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hello my name is Melissa Martucci and I'm a high school science teacher in the central valley
my district serves a high number of disadvantaged students we are very excited to see that the CAS
results have a link on the California dashboard for 2022 indicating the importance and relevance
of creating a scientifically literate community however with the high number of STEM jobs available
and low number of Californians from underrepresented student groups prepared for
these positions I feel it is of the utmost importance to place science on the dashboard
in a way that highlights and supports the need to increase diversity in STEM fields
to do this districts need to make science a priority districts rely heavily on indicators
from the dashboard for guidance on setting priorities thus I urge the state board of
education to include a performance level for the CAS the science test in 2023 so that all
districts and principals can make science a priority as they develop or refine their LCAP
plans and treat core areas equally especially in the elementary grades rather than masking its
presence thank you for your time and diligence in this matter thank you that concludes public
comment for item number three all right and it reminds us that the evolution of CAS is also
on the agenda that we heard about in this informational item now we can open up the
floor for discussion and any comments that folks would like to make about the evolution of the
system we will be looking by the way for an opportunity for a more in-depth conversation
among the board members about where assessments should and could go in our state but this is a
good introduction to some of what is being thought about in the department
yes member Glover Woods
thank you I had just a couple of questions and again just to reiterate I believe
President Darling-Hammond what you said and what we've heard throughout the presentation
regarding the importance and really the purpose of the assessment which is to guide instruction
for students and I really do believe that the evolution that we are going to see with our
assessments and assessment system will help to lead us closer to that goal I have two questions
one is in regard to the peer review and the second is in regard to the performance task pilot
that just took place so first for the peer review question I do realize that we received the I believe
fully meets ranking for the SBAC ELA and math blueprints but that was for the full form and
we are using the adjusted blueprint now can you give us some insight as to
if there will be a peer review of the adjusted blueprints and if so what the timeline will be
for us to know if those adjusted blueprints fully meet the peer review as the form full form does
so that's question number one that sounds like it goes to mal so mal if you can help us with that
is my mic on yes we can hear you okay yes although we are fully meet requirements for
our Smarter Balanced summative assessments for English and math are for the full form blueprints
so some the US Department of Ed did indicate that they are aware that we are using the adjusted
blueprints and they asked for some additional evidence that will be required to support the
adjusted blueprint forms and as as Smarter Balanced is working on the composite claim scores that we
hope to provide sometime this year to as additional evidence that the US Department of Ed will be
receiving to help us pass this additional step of requiring additional
evidence to support our adjusted blueprints and Tony I may feel free to add anything to
I think you covered most of it just add that the US Department I think is currently planning on
reviewing evidence in June Smarter Balanced was able to was not able to evaluate the
adjusted blueprint in spring of 21 because the participation was not consistent enough across
all of our members but then and then in spring 22 where we had a full administration we just finally
got all the data from our state so pretty long shadow between the administration and when
states are able to clean the data associated with the demographics and it's part of their production
process for ayp and now we're going to engage in those technical analyses in support of
a body of information available in june thank you tony and mal because I know that there is
of course strong support for utilizing the adjusted blueprint and being able to get that
feedback when it is appropriate to do so within all of the timelines you guys shared will be very
helpful and my second is actually not even a question just a comment about the performance
task pilot and first let me say how encouraging it is that that pilot continued even in the midst
of everything that was going on during our response to the pandemic and I'm quite encouraged
and excited that there will be an additional pilot that will give some more information
under I would say a more normal setting that we have so that that information can be utilized
and even compared to the information we received from the pilot that has just completed
with again knowing the goal is to really take those performance tasks and allow for them to be
a more integral part of instruction during the school year so again it meets that goal of helping
to drive and support teaching and learning and not just seen as kind of this thing we do at the end
of the year and then move forward from it so thank you again and thanks cheryl mount and tony for such
a comprehensive presentation. Thank you. Member Yoshimoto-Towry and then Member Escobedo.
Thank you Board President. I also wanted to thank the educators in the two districts knowing that
there were less than ideal you know situations at the time and the department and the consortium
because I think I was thinking about the four young people that were with us this morning
and the fact that all of their dreams depend on higher order thinking skills and the fact that
you know fixing climate change for example and the emphasis on fact speed accuracy
are necessary but they're not really sufficient particularly in this digital age where we can
get the recall on our smartphone so quickly so and I also just wanted to note that the what excited
me about the study was that the calibration of the performance task invites the grown-ups right
to do the same kind of collaboration and have the same kind of growth opportunities
so we're seeing that at multiple levels in the system when we have that and then so thank you
for that and then secondly I just had a comment about the the outreach opportunities there was
a chart in one of the handouts that listed all of the outreach opportunities for the the work
that's been done on CASP and I wanted to share just perhaps a suggestion that
in definitely in large districts but even in small and medium-sized districts
the data coordinators are often not the same people that are the heads of instruction the
heads that supervise schools and also the heads that that handle communication in the district
and so when I was a member of the trail urban district group the TUDA for the NAEP we had the
opportunity to bring the the head of instruction the head of the you know data the head of
communications together to learn this information that you shared today in a very brief setting
and then they could go back and talk with their data data representatives and I thought that that
was a really effective way of getting the information out and sort of heightening the
opportunity in front of all of us to use some of these incredible tools that you're developing
so I just wanted to recommend that as a as a next step thank you terrific thank you
member Escobedo and then member Rodriguez I just appreciate the innovation of California and the
efforts of elevating the okay in the system which is so drastically needed and I just wanted to ask
one is there any outreach to teacher preparation programs especially when I reflect on slide 35
where where teachers felt that preparing students for the performance task and planning for
instruction really ranked you know lower than than the other responses that you know as we
embark in this journey I hope that we're reaching out to teacher preparation programs
to ensure our teachers are well prepared from the beginning and understanding you know how to plan
and really instruct our students these type of higher level thinking skills because it's not
just the activity right but it's the type of questions you pose as well and it takes
collaboration to it takes really thoughtful planning so just just wondering if there are
any plans for that um is that a question you think for Tony yes yes yes Tony that's coming to you
thank you President Darling-Hammond and member Escobedo um it's uh it's a necessary step
and uh part of our we do have a strong relationship with California State University
through the EAP program and really CSU is a foundational guide for the consortium's assessment
design as a as a considered what does an assessment that measures college readiness
in k-12 look like and so there's a lot of of connections via that
incorporating the tools and the resources from the training into teacher prep programs has been
a challenge i would have to say and there's there's logistical issues there's um uh human
issues and dealing with humans always it'd be easier to deal with humans if we didn't have to
deal with humans i think um but um it's it just gets it gets complex so i think having a a state
level goal um to be able to incorporate some of these resources into higher ed curricula
might be a helpful positive force and if there's a way that we can convene uh interest in parties
that can help contribute to that um that direction i think that would help move things forward
but it's hard for us to do it at the consortium level um uh otherwise okay thank you thank you
tony uh member rodriguez yes thank you and thank you so much for uh what i see is a very uplifting
presentation the scene assessment and deeper learning and higher order thinking
all in the same presentation really fills me with uh with joy and hope uh when
you know i was i was very fortunate in 2000 when i was uh went through my teacher preparation program
and was trained in performance assessments and performance tasks uh deeper learning
and then suffered through teaching during no child left behind with you know a b or c
if you have any doubts choose c and i was ready to leave the profession and um i was in tears
when i ran into president darling hammond at a national board um conference and i told her i
said i i think i'm done and she said hang in there we have some great things coming down um you know
in california some great changes are are on the way and this was i think in 2008 uh when i when i
ran into her so i'm happy to see this this is the the horizon um and and performance tasks i think
um you know when when i think about like the national board process uh at tpas right you know
i think those are great preparations the because they're it's authentic assessment which is what
uh you know when i when i assess my students with performance tasks um or you know project tasks
they it's i get authentic information right you know like with the national board uh and in and in
my teacher prep where we would analyze gaps in students thinking based on their the performance
assessments and um so i think creating a practice of that uh and enforcing it with uh our own
teacher performance assessments is a wonderful step in this direction uh right and and taking
using assessment to guide deeper learning um now i did have a question and and i'm not sure if you
have information uh but you know with the 70 of teachers felt that the resources and performance
tasks were useful and i understand that's the circumstances um as member uh yoshimoto tari
mentioned probably weren't the best for some of the teachers because of everything that was
happening but did you have any information on the 30 percent who didn't what like maybe what they
felt that they needed more of or less of tony thank you uh i don't know specifically
helpful for us to analyze the data that way what we did here though is this uh the the gap between
when the teachers better understood the activities and uh the the specific instructional scope and
sequence that they had already planned so uh because we ended up starting this discussion
in fall uh and the district had already established a systematic date as to when
the interim assessment performance tasks were administered wasn't that coherence that we were
seeking uh from a teacher's perspective regarding the measure uh that they were
administering and the instruction that they were providing so uh i think uh had the professional
learning event around using the instructional tasks as a signal for instruction had that happened
in august or or during the professional learning events prior to the solidification of the
instructional plan we probably would have gotten more positive uh responses and that's something
that we're trying to consider as we think about what are the requisite uh elements that need to
be in place for this theory of action to to come into being thank you so much and lastly um uh in
regard to the higher order thinking and what uh member yoshimoto taori uh talked about you know
the students that we saw this morning and how those skills are necessary they're necessary
for problem solving and uh when i was in teacher prep school we used to call higher order thinking
skills the huts and um that was our you know like wanted to make sure that we had that in there so
you reminded me of that thank you all right thank you very much i think we've heard from
everyone who wants to contribute at this point as i say this will be an ongoing conversation
with members of the board so uh this is just a taste of what is to come i want to thank tony
and sheryl and mal for all of their presentations and this concludes this information item we can
take a little break uh it's 10 47 so i will see you back at uh 1102 see you then
please leave your uh stay in the meeting but just
stay in the meeting
right welcome back uh board members we need to reestablish a quorum so brooks is going to call
the roll member yoshimoto taori present member rodriguez present member porter present member
patillo brownson here member roscoe gonzalez here member olken
here member mcquillin here member lewis here vice president glover woods here
number escobedo here president garland hammond here most present
all right uh at this point we're going to take up item number four which is the approval of the
fiscal year 2022-23 career technical education incentive grant allocations including the
allocation formula the specific funding amounts and the number of grant awards the purposes for
the grant fund use and allowable and non-allowable expenditures i do understand that member yoshimoto
taori needs to recuse herself from this item so member yoshimoto taori please recuse yourself by
turning off your camera and microphone for the discussion and the vote thank you we'll let you
know when you can come back uh the cde recommends that we review and approve uh the formula funding
amounts uh and purposes for which grant funds may be used uh and the allowable and not allowable
expenditures there are two attachments that are part of the deliberations the item will be
presented by pete callis of the cde pete please begin good morning president darlene hammon state
board members and chief deputy nicely so i'm here to present on the california technical education
incentive grant program i'll talk about the program overview and funding the i'll do an
allocation example and then we'll request for approval of the allocations so an overview the
program was established as a state education economic and workforce development initiative
to provide pupils in kindergarten through grade 12 with knowledge and skills necessary to transition
to employment and post-secondary education the funding began in 2015 as a three-year program we
received 900 million dollars over three years the first year was 2015-16 we had 450 million
dollars with a one-to-one match requirement 2016-17 we had 300 million dollars with a 1.5
to 1 match requirement in 2017-18 we had 150 million dollars with a two-to-one match requirement
the funding was extended in 2018-19 through 2021 for 150 million dollars per year at a two-to-one
match in 2021-22 the funding amount was increased to 300 million dollars
of ongoing funds at a two-to-one match and this year 22-23 is 300 million dollars ongoing funding
with a two-to-one match
so an overview of this year for the funding CTIG is a formula-based competitive grant program
70 percent of the funding is for base calculated over calculated on the LEA's average daily
attendance 30 percent of the formula is based on eight positive considerations four positive
considerations are at five percent three positive considerations are at two percent each and one
positive consideration is at four percent there are three funding groups associated with the ADA
for each of the LEA's four percent of the funding or 12 million dollars is designated for applicants
with ADA of less than or equal to 140 eight percent or 24 million dollars is designated for
applicants with ADA of more than 140 but less than or equal to 550 88 percent of the funding
or 264 million dollars is designated for applicants with ADA of more than 550
2022-23 CTIG was determined by a formula calculation or the LEA match so in other words
the allocation for each of the LEA's was the lower of the two if the LEA had the
calculate their calculated allocation was lower than the match they received the allocation
if their calculated allocation was above their match they would receive up to their match for
their allocation and that's in statute so in 2022-23 the CTIG allocations for round 8a funds
available total funds available were 300 million dollars we had 383 total applications of the 383
375 applications were approved the total ask based on the LEA's match for all the applicants
we had an ask of 398 million 290 thousand 530 dollars total funds that we allocated
that we have allocated in the round 8a that we're asking for approval today is 265 million
572 thousand 347 dollars which leaves us we we are just completing around 8b for this funding
with a total amount available of 34 million four hundred and twenty seven thousand dollars
four hundred twenty seven thousand six hundred and fifty three dollars for round 8b
so an example of how we do the calculation for an allocation for one LEA and this is for a fictitious
school birch tree high school their ADA is 1000 their unduplicated pupil count is 900
of the positive considerations they are rural they have a high dropout rate a high unemployment
rate and the high collaboration across with other entities so their base rate of for they fall into
the upper level category of over 550 ADA so their base is calculated on nine ninety six dollars and
sixty four cents per ADA times a thousand which leaves them with their ADA share is ninety six
thousand six hundred and forty dollars they are considered rural their rural rate is forty one
dollars and fifty four cents per ADA which gives them a rural share of forty one thousand five
hundred and forty dollars their next positive consideration is their collaboration share which
is six dollars and thirty six cents per ADA that gives them sixty three hundred and sixty dollars
for their collaboration share their unduplicated count is five dollars and eight cents per
unduplicated remember that calculation is based on 900 not a thousand which gives their unduplicated
share four thousand five hundred and seventy two dollars the dropout rate the high dropout rate
calculation is eight dollars and seventy four cents per ADA which gives them eight thousand seven
hundred and forty dollars and then their high unemployment rate share is based on seventeen dollars
and twelve cents so they would receive seventeen thousand one hundred and twenty dollars their total
calculation added up between the base and all their positive considerations is one hundred and seventy
four thousand nine hundred and seventy two dollars their maximum match was the two to one match was
two hundred and twenty thousand so you can see they were their allocation is based on their total
calculation because it's the lower of the two numbers it's below their match
so our recommendation CDE recommends approval of the career technical
education incentive grant program 2022-23 allocations
all right thank you so much Pete we're going to put up the public comment slide we'll open the phone
line now for the public comment queue members of the public wishing to provide comment may do so by
calling the telephone number and using the access code shown on this slide and while we're waiting
I'd like to ask our is our liaisons member McQuillin and member Rodriguez
if they have any initial comments member McQuillin
yes thank you I want to say thank you to Peter for all the work on this and you know
when I think of CTE in this whole area you know I think we're just realizing what this means to us
in the state of California and our future workforce you know the skills based positions
that CTE represents you know from IT and the computers we're on right now for them to function
well and and when we have problems with them it's the CTE folks who are going to come and repair them
or I think of all the the wave of EV vehicles electric vehicles and what are we going to do
when they break down I mean this area is becoming so important to to us and our futures
here in California I really appreciate the breakdown and you giving those examples of
how the allocations are are are given out Pete you know in incorporating areas where there's
high unemployment in the rural areas getting recognized and some points there there are really
some differences in California when you think of the jobs CTE jobs in rural areas compared to our
urban areas so I appreciate that area very much so it's a you presented a very high
rate of those who did succeed I think it was only eight or nine who did not succeed in their
applications I'm wondering if there were any themes there of any of those applications who
did not get funded but anyway thank you for your work in the presentation we can come back to that
question later on thank you so much member Rodriguez also thank you for the presentation
and member McQuillin covered everything thank you terrific are there any clarifying questions
that anyone has before we go to public comment
I'm not seeing any of those so let's see if there's anybody in the public comment queue
we don't have any callers in the queue so that concludes public comment for item number four
all right so we can now open it up for board discussion
and member McQuillin if you want to ask that question of Mr. Callis please feel free and any
other questions that folks have or comments if I could just if there were any themes of folks who
did not get funded any themes of those applications that were not successful thank you yeah so I can
address that a majority of them as you said there were eight or nine a majority of them just did
not complete the application process and we reached out to them even after the the closing date
to assist them if they wanted to you know if something happened tech like you were talking
about earlier if technology fails we're there to assist them and we followed up with all of
the applicants that did not complete their applications to assist them with completion
some of them chose to not move forward with them
they have a chance in the eight b round to go after it again right if they were not successful
correct thank you
terrific and you know thanks to the staff for doing that you know careful follow-up
if there are no other questions or comments then we can take a motion
so i have a motion to approve the allocations member Bacallan yes do I see your hand go up
I'll make that motion to approve all right and I'll second it thank you member Rodriguez is
there any other discussion if not Brooks will call the roll for the vote member Yoshimoto
vote member Yoshimoto sorry recused member Rodriguez yes member Porter yes member Petillo
Brownson yes member Roscoe Gonzales yes member Olken yes member McQuillan yes member Lewis
yes vice president Glover-Woods yes member Escobedo yes president Darling-Hammond yes motion carries
all right so at this point we're a little early we're a little ahead of our schedule
it and we can take a break for lunch an early lunch our next item is probably a good hour
and a half long item so we don't I don't want to get us started on that and then you know we
make it hangry before the end of it so those of you who work in high schools are familiar with
the staged lunches you know just think of yourself as getting the first lunch
in the three or four that are being offered and so we will stop here and reconnoiter at about 11 45
all right welcome back from that leisurely lunch that's a an indulgence we don't normally get
board members we need to reestablish a quorum so Brooks is going to call the roll
member Yoshimoto-Towry present member Rodriguez here member Porter here member Petillo-Brownson
here member Petillo-Brownson here member Roscoe-Gonzalez here member Olken here
member McQuillan here member Lewis here vice president Glover-Woods here member Escobedo
here president Garland-Hammond here everyone's present all right here we go
item five is the update on the implementation of the integrated local state and federal
accountability and continuous improvement system information item related to the
implementation and use of school climate surveys to improve outcomes as required in the state
board of education adopted local indicator self-reflection tool for priority six which
is school climate this is an information item no action is recommended at this time the item will
be presented by William McGee of the department of education Rebecca Serna and Tom Hanson of West
Ed and Nicole DeWitt and Sharon Rubocava of San Diego Unified William great to see you please begin
great thank you and good afternoon to everyone hello president Darling-Hammond vice president
Glover-Woods state board of education members superintendent chief deputy officer staff and
community my name is William McGee i'm the division director of the student achievement
and support division and we are happy to be here today to discuss our item so just a little bit of
an overview for you all we appreciate the opportunity to explore priority six self-reflection
tool and to be able to provide background on the tool and an overview the center for school climate
at west ed will talk about their work and supporting california's lea's as well as introducing
lea to talk about their practices and utilizing the tool this was great because it provided an
opportunity at continued collaboration collaboration my team unity sacremoto and
radine girola collaborated with the whole child division tom herman and hilva chan and this was
an opportunity for me as a new member of cde to meet the west ed team and san diego unified
school district so we're excited that the board is engaged in this conversation today
so i'll read this slide just to ground us in the work of local indicator performance standards
for the local indicators the state board of education adopted performance standards that
require an lea to annually measure its progress and meeting the requirements of the specific
lcff priority report the results as a part of a non-consent item at the same public meeting of
local governing board body at which the l cap is adopted and report results to the public
through the dashboard utilizing the state board of education adopted self-reflection tools for
each local indicator an lea uses the state board of education adopted self-reflection tools to
report its progress through the dashboard the collection and reflection on locally available
relevant to progress regarding local priority areas is intended to support leas in completing
the self-reflection tools reporting in the dashboard and in local planning and improvement
efforts a little bit about the self-reflection tool history for priority six in 2016 the board
adopted priority six reflection tool and then in response to improvement in the tool in 2017
the cde convened the school conditions and climate work group which then looked at the tool made
some recommendations and the state board then revised priority six and so basically the revisions
with the recommendations are what we are using now for the priority six self-reflection tool
in this presentation we'll touch on all of the various components of the l cap template and
instructions lea's are to provide a narrative summary of the local administration and analysis
of a local climate survey the survey is to be conducted at a minimum every other year
a narrative of the survey should be input on the california school dashboard which then is made
public
lea's will have an opportunity to include differences among student groups from the survey
for surveys that provide an overall score the lea can report the overall score for all students
and student groups the lea may also include an analysis of a subset of specific items
and additional data collection tools that are relevant
to the school conditions and the climate to really help them narrow down what they're working with
here is the priority six school climate self-reflection tool
so again it's all about data meaning and use when reporting on the dashboard
an lea shall include these components data reflect on the results and share what the lea learned
meaning making sense of the data breaking it down by grade level student group what does the data
show us strengths and or growth areas for the lea and finally use making the data actionable
how will the lea utilize the data to make changes
and or strengthen and continue practices that are effective
while a comprehensive analysis was not done a review of three counties with the total of 258
lea's show very few lea's disaggregated data via student groups at the local levels lea's
disaggregate the data for their local review context for grade span topics and other items
not many lea's disaggregated their data based on specific student groups
cde in partnership with west ed hosted a webinar on december 5th
digging deeper into school climate to inform your l cap there were over 380 participants who
joined the webinar to learn various topics such as how lea's can explore school climate data to
be included in l caps ways to dig deeper and understand school climate data anaheim union
high school district's approach with engaging educational partners in this process was highlighted
here
what west ed does is they provide different levels of support to california's lea's
they hosted a series of webinars through from january through june where over 200 lea's participated
west ed also created a trauma-informed module used for california healthy kids survey
which was completed and in use now
the investment in the school climate at west ed led to the establishment of the california center
for school climate in january 2022 which will provide school climate and data use trainings
data use trainings and support lea's through june 30th 2024 and now i would like to turn
it over to rebecca cerna and tom hansen from the california center for school climate
so
thank you well as i adjust this okay all right so again um my name is rebecca cerna from west ed
and i'm here representing the california center for school climate and at the same time acknowledging
the team that works alongside me in these efforts i'm here to provide a
context about california center for school climate ccsc and about the importance of
school climate so at the center we have four goals that we work towards we work towards providing
a relevant and responsive school climate coaching supports to lea's into districts
and also to support lea's with data use in terms of best practices for using for collecting for
using and for monitoring school climate data we also serve as a connector across the state for
lea's and also help them in supporting the dissemination of best practices already in
existence we also support lea's in in strengthening those relationships that they have with their
educational partners
so our center launched in january or the center launched in january of last year
so it has and we have funding through june of 2024 and through the ccsc we provide various
supports for example we provide school climate data use virtual sessions like what will mention
that we provided that we collaborated on with anaheim union high school district we also have
had a session where we collaborated with u county office of ed and in paradise unified school
district where they highlighted how they used their school climate data in an effort to support
post-disaster mobilization efforts after the fire that they experienced in their community
we also offer peer learning exchanges where our smaller opportunities for districts to come
together and have conversations around topics of discussion related to school climate topics that
are selected based on inquiry surveys that they complete we have collaborated with agencies in
hosting these peer learning exchanges such as children now and also school districts like davis
joint unified school district we offer school climate professional learning supports
we host an annual virtual event our next one is scheduled for february 28th and our registration
for that event will be live on monday where we will be highlighting sessions on community schools
on culturally responsive pedagogy on how relationships are critical for data use
practices we have a panel for that session as well and we're culminating the event with our
youth advisory team now and we also develop resources for the field such as briefs and
toolkits we co-developed a toolkit with our youth advisory team a group of high school
students from across california where they developed activities on how to cultivate caring
relationships among staff and students and we have an audio gallery that hosts audio casts
highlighting some best practices across the field for example we have one that we worked on with
shasta county office of education where they highlighted how they co-design culturally
responsive practices with their tribal partners or one that we collaborated with bahadur valley
unified school district on a community-based approach of towards student and family well-being
so those are some of the those things that we do in an effort to support a positive school climate
so when we're talking about school climate we really frame it under the definition of the national
center for school climate which it's it's focused on the conditions and the quality
of a school environment that affects the attitudes the behaviors the performance of students and
staff so it's about the relationships the trusting relationships about the goals and the norms that
exist about the teaching and learning that happens in the school and about those organizational
structures and policies that are there and it's all framed under three domains so our three
domains are also adapted from the national center for safe and supportive learning environments and
from cde's previous work through california safe and supportive schools work so we frame it under
belonging and connections under safety and wellness and environment and under the those three domains
there are sub-domains that exist so for example under belonging and connections it's about the
relationships and how that's foundational and that has a terrible effect on engaging educational
partners and on school engagement and student agency and when we think about safety and wellness
we're thinking about the safety of individuals not just physical safety but emotional and
psychological safety and we have mental health and wellness supports under safety and wellness
and then under environment we're really thinking about the physical environment behavioral supports
instructional environment and diversity equity and inclusion so this framing has really helped
support districts and really thinking about what are those indicators that they need to be exploring
in order to continuously monitor school climate data so all of these efforts
come together you know to support meaningful learning because we know that meaningful learning
happens when all members of the school community feel safe emotionally mentally psychologically
and physically valued cared for respected and are engaged
and their research is growing around school climate and there's more and more research and
it's all very similar when students report that they feel that they attend schools with a positive
school climate they report higher levels of school motivation and connectedness there is higher
levels of attendance there's they score higher on measures of academic performance they're more
willing to report possible threats safety threats and they're more positive towards their learning
and it's not just about the positive impacts on the students it's also about the positive impacts
of the adults in the building so when educators perceive that they work in schools with a positive
school climate it's they have higher levels of job satisfaction there's less burnout they leave
the profession less they're more invested in the learning of the students and we think about that
and then we go deeper so these are like research studies but then we go deeper and we take a look
at the data in our in our state and fortunately in california we have access to great sources
of school climate surveys one of them being the california healthy kids survey
and and this really highlights where why this is also important for california when we have
33 percent of our seventh graders reporting that they're experiencing chronic sadness and
hopelessness when 28 percent of them are reporting social emotional distress or when we look at our
high school students that they report 63 report feeling safe and very safe at school that means
that 37 are not and when 59 report feeling that they're connected to school 40 are not being
connected to school so that really highlights why this is critical and important to our students
and to the adults who work in it at our schools so we have it's you know what's also important
you know we have survey data but what's also important is to also ask the students so i
mentioned that we have a youth advisory team as part of ccsc and we have six students that
are representing the youth advisory team and three of them made this video to highlight
what school climate means to them and why it's important so
hello and welcome my name is amaya farias 11th grader at casso world will fundamental high school
in san juan unified school district and my name is julian brickwood sclar 12th grader at
serratoga high school in the los gatos serratoga joint union high school district
my name is alexa southpaw 10th grader at eastlake high school in sweetwater union high school
district we are all members of the california center for school climates youth advisory team
a team of six members representing several regions across california in our work with ccsc we provide
input as well as help to create resources for schools and districts this past spring we
contributed activities to a resource called cultivating caring relationships toolkit which
contains activities that help to strengthen staff student relationships we're here today to share
our perspective about the importance of school climate a positive school climate is important
to me because in order for youth to feel welcomed and comfortable students to feel accepted for
their different cultures backgrounds identities or ideas an environment that allows for people to
be themselves without the worry of bullying harassment or judgment really creates a more
secure and independent person ready for life after school these strong relationships and
strong support groups that come with this positive climate can be really helpful for a young person's
mental health and overall experience when it comes to social academic or personal lives
a positive school climate to me is an environment that works to comfortably increase genuine
relationships between peers on campus so that teachers and students are structured and supported
when learning succeeding and struggling to add on to what amaya said a positive school climate to
me is a place where students are encouraged to embrace their individuality it allows students
to have peers and staff to go to if they ever need help by supporting students both academically
and non-academically it sets students up for long-term success thank you all for being here
today and working toward making schools a positive place for all to be as members of the youth
advisory team we look forward to continuing to contribute to the work of this california center
for school climate so when we look at data it's important to reach out you know to students and
to continue to explore so now i'm going to pass it to tom hansen who's going to share
oh i'm just trying to move it forward
hello and on measuring school climate
so
great thank you rebecca thank you youth advisory team and thank you president darling hammond and
the california state board of education what i plan to present here is a brief description
of the state of the state regarding the measurement of school climate with standardized
psychometrically validated student surveys
first
sorry there we go okay so first just to keep these top of mind let's just review the lcf
priority six school climate indicators the state indicator is the suspension rate it's the percent
of students who were suspended for one full day during the school year we the indicators both
for current rates and then changes over time the local indicator is assessed by local climate
surveys that capture valid measures of student perceptions of schools student safety and student
perceptions of school connectedness the requirement is that the school climate
survey be administered at least every other year and i believe that the annual that there's an
annual reporting requirement
okay so the most commonly used school climate surveys in california are the california healthy
kids survey panorama educations student survey and the youth truth student survey
the california healthy kids survey and youth truth those those surveys are administered
anonymously to students panorama education survey is administered so that respondents can be tracked
over time there are others as well there's the core sel school culture survey that's administered
by approximately 22 districts in the state it includes a lot of the large districts in the
state note that the core surveys administered by districts that administer the core oftentimes
also administer the chks and other survey tools there's also the pbis school climate survey that's
administered by about 15 districts in the state and plus there are many other sort of locally
created surveys some with support from other organizations like handover research or gallup
and some just independently with with by the school districts themselves
okay so this table shows that between 2021 and 2122 those two academic years the california healthy
kids survey was administered in 695 districts 299 of those districts administered the survey
annually so that's 695 districts that represents about 66 67 percent of the
school districts in the state panorama education was administered in 202 districts
pretty much all of the panorama education surveys are administered annually and then
the youth truth was administered in 80 80 districts so if you add those numbers up
come to a figure around in the high 900s like 977 and that that sort of that number is
that's a lot of the districts in the state and so the reason that number is so high is because
many districts administer multiple surveys during that time
the main story here is that the vast majority of districts
administer
oh okay the main story here again is the vast majority of districts in the state
administer standardized school climate student surveys
this next slide shows the areas where dimensions of school climate assessed by these surveys
chks california healthy kids survey panorama and youth truth all measure perceptions of
school connectedness and belonging and school safety although they measure it differently
and all measure other important dimensions of school climate caring staff student relationships
high expectations school engagement
i just want to point out some of the strengths of the three main surveys
first multi-item measures of school connectedness and safety are available
available multi-item measures are better to cover broad topics like school connectedness
and school belonging just like we would not want to rely on a single test item to measure
reading comprehension we do not want to rely on a single questionnaire item to measure
school belonging or some such concept
multi-item measures also reduce measurement error and improve the precision of the measure
making the measures more appropriate for for examining trends over time
for continuous improvement purposes
the other important strength is that the measures assessed on these standardized
surveys have been psychometric psychometrically validated so statistical analysis have been
conducted to provide evidence that the measures measure what they are intended to measure
and that they are reliable they basically meet established standards of reliability and validity
as you saw above the survey measures also measure other important aspects of school climate
student voice meaningful participation perceptions of the physical environment
peer relationships all three of the surveys assess mental and behavioral health indicators
the chks assesses chronic sadness emotional distress suicide contemplation and other more
positive aspects of health like optimism the chks the chks with the chks cde has implemented
a system that sort of identifies districts or schools that have abnormally high suicide
contemplation scores so as data are processed west ed runs some codes identifies sort of schools
and districts where the suicide ideation rates are are far above the average and then
we notify cde about these rates and then cde notifies the school district
and or the school and provides informational resources to address these high rates of suicide
ideation another strength is that all three surveys are customizable and all three have
parallel school staff and family surveys so this allows for triangulation of the data for student
staff and parent reports and finally all three platforms provide data via accessible dashboards
to disaggregate data for student groups and monitor trends for all students and
for student groups to aid continuous improvement efforts
okay this this next slide we've already presented this so we'll present this earlier
but it very loosely describes suggested reporting requirements for the local indicator
as will described the self-reflection tool emphasizes reporting with respect to data
meaning and use of results with respect to data and meaning lea's are asked to report and reflect
on scores for all students and disaggregated results for student groups with respect to use
use lea's are asked to report on actions that will be implemented in response to the results
and the extent to which results reflect the impacts of previously implemented actions
so this next set of slides just provides an example of how the chks data dashboard provides data
in a form that can be helpful for continuous improvement efforts
and can be used to disaggregate data for student groups one simply selects
sort of the entity sort of the domain and a measure
in this case perceived safety at school and pardon the resolution of this graphic but this this
graphic shows the trends and perceived school safety over an eight-year period for a school
district you can also identify disaggregate data by 15 characteristics this includes sort of a proxy
for english language proficiency gender gender identity living situation which includes being
the living situation includes being unhoused students reports of being unhoused or living
with a foster family there's parental education and race ethnicity so let's see the results for
race ethnicity here we see that white and asian students report substantially higher rate levels
of safety at school than african-americans latinx and multi-ethnic students so one can also use
these data to look at trends by student group to determine whether disparities are shrinking
or growing across time and again all three surveys the main surveys they have this capacity
okay i'm going to pass it back to rebecca
and she's going to talk about data use in action
okay thank you tom so what does this look like in the field the you know schools you know
administer these surveys and they use them for their requirements and also
these measures allow these indicators allow educators and their educational partners
with the data needed to really think about what are their strengths what are the things that
they should be celebrating that they're doing well and what are those opportunities for growth
the needs that they have it also helps to support to identify what goals how to monitor progress
so as we engage in the work of creating positive school climates that local context is so important
it's so critical to be able to look by the different characteristics that are available
by the by the survey that they might be using and to prioritize what they should be focusing on
but you know effective use of the data is not just about having access to the data it's also
about engaging your educational partners in these conversations and so that is part of like what we
are doing through the california center for school climate we're working towards trying to build that
capacity around data use specifically around school climate data use and will mentioned
earlier how we host a series of webinars around school climate data use practices
in last spring between like january and june we hosted a series of webinars attended by 600
participants representing 201 leas in california another example of another one that we hosted was
one on street data and centering student-centered approaches to school transformation and we
collaborated with the street data authors and with the national center for social emotional
learning and school safety to host that session we also have as part of ccsc a school climate
data use community of practice where we're working with nine school districts in providing supports
around data use and what we do is we facilitate a data use workshop where we work with their teams
with all of their educational partners in doing a data discovery in data mapping and really goal
setting so that it can inform their sipsa plan so that it can inform their lcat plans we also host
virtual community practice sessions where we bring together the we're bringing together all of the
participating leas and on topics that have been identified by these specific leas that are part
of this community of practice and we provide individual coaching supports to these districts
in order to offer them that differentiated support that they might need because some of
these nine districts some are very rural and small and then we have a really a really large
school district that's part of this group as well so one example of a district is center joint unified
school district not too far from here we've facilitated their data use workshop and where
they brought together school staff administrators both at the district level and at the school level
they had counselors they had parents they had fifth grade students and we engaged all
of their seven schools and conversations around data and and they've also identified some areas
of focus that they want to work on they're trying to work on desegregating their local school climate
survey data in this case it's panorama survey that they're using and engaging their educational
partners in data conversations including students family members and staff and and to disseminate
what are some best practice approaches to disseminate their local school climate survey
results and as part of this work we have some county offices of ed have also reached out to us
in terms of trying to you know that they're also interested in having building that capacity
around data use and in march we're going to be launching a peer network for county offices of ed
as part of the center as well so now i am going to pass it to san diego unified there is many
examples of other districts you know doing a lot of work in san diego unified has been well on
their journey exploring their school climate data use and so we have with us today nicole dewitt
executive director of student services at san diego unified and share and ruval cava a program
manager of counseling and guidance at san diego unified so i'm going to pass it to nicole
thank you so much for allowing us the opportunity to share the work that we're doing in san diego
unified our district's use of school culture and climate data is really reflected prominently in
goal one of our local control accountability plan goal one for our district focuses on cultivating
inclusive anti-racist and restorative communities here you can see our cycle of continuous
improvement for our l cap a process that starts with an annual board workshop in june of each year
with progress monitoring and feedback gathered throughout the month of september through may
specifically in goal one our actions we take as a district on this slide you can see those actions
highlighted which include providing restorative schools and classroom communities implementation
of site equity teams access to wellness services structures for responding to students mental health
needs and elevating student voice in order to measure progress for those action items we
utilize the cal school survey with an emphasis on the safety caring relationships high expectations
and meaningful participation strength in addition to the cal schools data we also use a variety of
internal metrics that include monthly data tracking for the number of counselor contacts
mental health referrals and suicide risk assessments as well as real-time data dashboards
that sync to our student information system and disaggregate data related to suspension rates
expulsions and chronic absenteeism during our last progress monitoring cycle we highlighted
the following from the california healthy kids survey for our educational partners to help us
determine what action steps we may need to revise our ad on this slide you can see trends for our
elementary schools over the past five years that show a need for growth in the areas of caring
relationships and social emotional learning for our middle school students we see similar areas
of need related to school connectedness and caring adult relationships we also paid close
attention to the five-year trends related to students experiencing chronic sadness and
hopelessness although the data shows a change rate of plus or minus four the overall number
still highlights a significant amount of students approximately one-third reporting that they have
experienced these feelings for high school we performed above the state average in the strands
of school connectedness and caring adult relationships however we did see decreases
in both areas since the beginning of the pandemic we also again focused on the percentage of students
experiencing chronic sadness and hopelessness which had a net change of zero but was higher
than our middle school rates examining our cal schools data along with the other metrics
outlined led us to revise action steps during our last LCAP board workshop during that workshop we
highlighted the need to provide a continuum of social emotional and mental health services
that included ongoing counselor training mental health services and education lessons for our
high schools the expansion of our social emotional learning programs at elementary and middle levels
and community partners to assist in assessing the mental health and social emotional needs
of our high schools in addition we also plan to implement proactive measures in an effort to
increase school connectedness and caring relationships through the establishment of
family services assistants assigned to each neighborhood who focus on decreasing chronic
absenteeism by removing barriers to needed services i would now like to invite my colleague
Sharon Rubikova our program manager for counseling and guidance to speak about the
ways school sites have incorporated the cal schools data into site specific goals
thank you nicole i could just share the fun stuff so what we're going to be sharing in the next few
slides is an overview of how we're using the healthy kids data or actually the cal schools data
within the school plans for student achievement overall but also i'm going to dive into how
counselors being the program manager of counseling guidance kind of have to share the counseling
how counselors really drive their students to be successful in their work and in their
how counselors really drive their their programs so close to 80 percent of our schools are
formulating goals from the data that is received from the cal schools data so that out of the
80 percent we have 272 goals and beyond looking at it more we have 63 percent of the goals
really are dealing with the parent and guardian data that we receive and the goals are more
involving the involvement the parent involvement the input in decision making perception from
our participation excuse me from all parent and guardian groups 37 percent of the goals
are using the data from students and mainly the caring relationships meaningful participation
and safety so what does that mean okay with the schools we're going to highlight at each level
the first level that we are going to be highlighting is the elementary school level
robin erickson is the school counselor and she started at speckles in 2019 and trying to formulate
the comprehensive school counseling program at speckles she was reviewing the data and the data
that she was reviewing was the chicks data that we have and she noticed that there is a there is a
need for student connectedness and meaningful participation so from this what she's been able
to do is to add programs that make kids want to get to school so for instance no place for
hate they're in their third year of no place for hate the one that um and the kids just she's she's
a model school for the no place for hate program through the anti-definition league the art
enrichment through volunteers for all students what she was able to do is build a community
relationship with a program and have volunteers art teachers come and teach all students so from
these those are just two examples of many programs that she started she has seen growth as well as
gains and students want to come to school so she this is something she reflects on yearly but um
you know using the california school data she's been able to see progress or improvement louis
middle school this is an example of what tom was speaking of earlier what dina weiss the head
counselor there what she is able to do is she does staff meetings and she takes the information from
the student data the staff data as well as the parent guardian data and then she just lays it
out on the table and says how is everybody's perception and she does this yearly with staff
and she doesn't just do the current data she references last year this year and she has been
able to kind of build programs within at louis middle school with this data as well the two
programs the two problems that she was seeing at louis middle school and and by problems they
weren't huge problems but something that needed to be addressed was the caring relationships
that middle school students found as well as safety so from this what she was able to do
was restructure the placement of staff during lunch as well as during passing periods
in order to have the staff be more visible and the students felt more safe they also felt that
they had could say hi and it wasn't just within a classroom so with with just making that little
pivot she was able to have improvement on her scores the classroom lessons is an ongoing thing
that they're doing at louis and they work with another group within san diego unified to do
bystander conversation and not just let slurs happen so this is something once again that
is looked upon yearly and finding improvement okay the high school so high school crofford
heimei chavez there what heimei did was was looking at the data and just by first glance
you would not think that crofford would have a problem because the what the data with that
he was referencing was the alcohol use drug use as well as baking and there weren't a lot of
students that were participating in daily activity or even trying this but what he figured out was
even though students weren't participating they didn't think it was harmful so and that was like
red flag so what he was able to do is he was able to utilize an outside agency community agency to
come in and to do education and workshops and and he was able to deliver this and has been able to
deliver this in the freshman pe class as well as rot rotc so which is a scary thought that the kids
may not participate but they don't see anything wrong if they were offered so once again heimei
did an amazing job and continues to do such at crofford high school the last example that i'm
going to deal with is morris high school morris high school we actually have an intervention
counselor there and what an intervention counselor does not typically have a normal caseload but is
able to really impact students on a deeper level hence interventions and so what what she was able
to do at morris high school was take the chick's data but then formulate her own needs assessment
and from the needs assessment she was able to get students the help that they need the two i think
that are most prominent here is the food insecurity healthy kids data doesn't give the
food insecurity but what she was able to do was to formulate the questions from the safety questions
that she had on the chicks data and then pinpoint that there were kids actually that were going home
with no food so she was able to align the community resources to those students and not only just do
that one time thing she checks in with them to make sure that the food insecurity is not an issue
another problem that she was seeing on her campus was that the students didn't have friends and
these are students that wanted to have friends and so what she was able to do is peers or have
students paired up with a peer mentoring program and from this they do check-ins the students feel
like they have a voice and they are feeling more connected to the school site so and with that that
unified story i would like to pass it back to will
great thank you for that informative presentation i just want to say thank you to nicole and
sharon as well as tom herman and tom hansen and hilva rebecca unity and ray dean for all their
work with this and so now we will turn it over to public comment
thank you so much to all of the presenters that was really informative
while we're opening up the phone line for public comment those who would like to comment
can do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that
is shown now and then i want to ask our liaison vice president glover woods if she has any initial
comments before i add my own vice president glover woods yes and thank you to everyone who
gave the presentation definitely appreciate the time that went into bringing forward the
data as well as the real life experiences in san diego unified i think i'll frame my
brief comments and i may have others once we come back for board discussion but i think i'll frame
my comments with a statement that one of the students said on the video that we saw and one
of the students said that school needs to be a positive place for all to be and i really
feel that that statement says it all our school climate data really serves almost as a foundation
for all of the other data because how students experience school very often shows up in many
other aspects that we look at as far as data is concerned on the dashboard and beyond so as we
think about it i just want to and as i said i'll probably come back with a more in-depth comment
regarding this but i want to really kind of bring our thoughts and minds to the desegregation
of the school climate data we know that it is a may do for our leas it's not something that they
must do and as was shared at the beginning of the presentation the large majority of leas are not
disaggregating their school climate data by student group and the concern in regards to
that is as actions are planned and implemented those actions might miss the mark if that
disaggregated student group information is not front and center to really show again the experiences
of all we want the student voice and sometimes the most pervasive student voice we will get
is from this survey data so um president darley ham and i think i'll kind of just kind of end
my comment there um again i reserve the right to come back and say more i'm very passionate
about this and very passionate about all voices being heard but as i said i think i will just
put a period at the end of that right now until we come back for more conversation
that sounds great um thank you for getting us going and i'll just add how important this is i
want to second the remarks that vice president glover woods has made um you know clearly if
school is in a place that people feel safe and uh carrying environment it's not a place you're
going to want to be in as we're looking at chronic absenteeism rates that have uh gone up and the
anxiety that students you know have experienced during this endemic that we're in now and for
lots of other reasons it's very very important that we um really get the most out of the ability
to use these kinds of data to make um changes in the ways that schools operate where that is
important to do uh the um there was a national survey that is done periodically not too long
ago that found that fewer than 30 of secondary school students in the country felt that they
were in a caring and um supportive environment so there's a lot of work to do to to create those
kinds of environments and we know from the science of learning and development that in fact uh social
and emotional and academic development are like completely linked that we learn much more
effectively when we feel a sense of trust and belonging when we're not being stigmatized when
we're not experiencing trauma and to build a climate in which all of that is taking place
it just takes a lot of explicit effort in schools to you know to create the kind of community and
supports and these data can be very very helpful as Vice President Glover Woods said the
disaggregation of the data is also incredibly informative and useful in that process so very
helpful to be brought up to speed on where we are in the state around this and I look forward to
to the public comment and the discussion and to see what else we want to be thinking about as we
really help schools create the kind of environments that will bring students in keep them there and
enable them to learn most optimally with that I think we want to open unless there are any
clarifying questions let me just see is there any specific clarifying question that anyone has that
they want to ask of the presenters if and after that we'll go to public comment and we'll come
back to discussion so let's go to public comment at this point do we have any buddy queued up for
public comment yes we do it looks like we have nine people in the queue I will open the phone line
three terrific good afternoon please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time starts now Hi my name is Amanda Dickey I'm the Executive Director of Government
Relations for the Santa Clara County Office of Education and I really appreciate the great
conversation today around the use of climate surveys and collecting this data on an ongoing
basis particularly I want to mention how helpful having this data has been in implementing the
student behavioral health incentive program which is part of the CYBHI or the Children's
and Youth Behavioral Health Incentive Program you know that that data from our districts and the
fact that they regularly participated and collecting data from students really actually helped us get
so many steps ahead many other counties in implementing these types of programs and these
investments because we have been looking at that data for a long time and it was really telling us
you know how severe the mental health needs of students were and and really helped us identify
the kinds of services and kinds of spaces that they needed and we we used that information both
to complete the needs assessment that was required through SBHIP the Student Behavioral Health Incentive
Program but also really to inform you know how we decided to allocate funds and prioritize
funding so that we were you know our plan is to we have launched the Student Wellness Centers
on 12 campuses opening another seven this year and we'll continue you know to to be looking at
the student climate and information as we move forward thank you. Thank you. Next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now.
Hi my name is Lily Rosenberger I'm a management analyst at the Kern County Office of Education
I'd like to thank the board for highlighting the impact of school climate on student success
as an LCAP reviewer I have firsthand knowledge on the efforts LEAs are making to analyze and use
school climate data to drive their continuous improvement efforts we're seeing districts use
this data to get to the root causes of other student outcome data such as suspensions academic
achievement and attendance because of the challenge many districts not only in Kern County but across
the state are facing in regards to chronic absenteeism LEAs are actually prioritizing school
climate data to make improvements as a matter of fact this year we had over 30,000 students take
an additional school connectedness survey to try to get at the story behind chronic absenteeism data
some of the actions we're seeing districts take based on this data is providing professional
learning on trauma-informed practices and cultural proficiency and prioritizing funding for NTSS PBIS
and social emotional learning this need has been so great in our county that our office has created
a new department focused on equity and inclusion to support our district's improvement efforts
thank you so much for your attention this afternoon thank you next caller please state
your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
my name is Jessica Pregalski I work as the director of data and engagement at the Sonoma
county office of education I'm going to be calling on behalf of my organization and the 40 school
districts we serve I want to offer our appreciation of and support for the state
focus on school climate data locally we've come to rely on the youth truth survey as a powerful
tool for our own continuous improvement within and across LEAs our local youth truth effort
grew from two pilot high schools back in 2017 to more than 142 school sites across 30 school
districts this year we've heard from 60,000 Sonoma county students staff and family members and that
information has been strategically used to inform and even integrated into LCAPs across
state priority areas in an effort to improve the academic and life outcomes of our students and
their families the youth truth survey allows us to monitor for whom those efforts are working and
for whom they're not we're actually able to disaggregate reports across more than 13 demographic
subgroups that reveal insights related to our students with disabilities multilingual learners
students of color among others so super excited and appreciative that we're able to spotlight
our local school climate effort that's become an integral part about how we think about doing
school in Sonoma county thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for
the record you have one minute your time starts now good afternoon my name is Sally Fox and I
represent the California Association for Bilingual Education CAVE school climate is important in
providing the necessary socio-cultural environment for success for our 1.1 million English learners
item five implementation and use of school climate surveys for priority six is an opportunity for
improvement if we require LEAs to report survey results by student groups and overall score for
all on another note having a set of four to five key questions that are standard for all LEAs
would help compare data statewide please help LEAs do better by requiring them to analyze
surveys and make appropriate changes for the better thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hello Chair Darling-Hammond and board members my name is Dr. Ashley Girvin and I'm an instructional
coach at desert sands unified school district and a teach plus california policy fellow
understanding school culture and climate from only an educator's perspective limits our ability
to meet the needs of all students when schools look at culture and climate data teachers
administrators counselors and other staff members are able to assess specific needs of students
implement supports and monitor progress thank you for taking the time to explore this issue and work
that the department and what they are doing to support the use of this data more effectively
nevertheless we were disappointed to learn that the 150 000 designated in the 2021 education budget
trailer bill to begin this process did not move this critical work forward we hope that the state
board and department of education can put forward recommendations to get this process back on track
my teach plus policy fellows and i would love to partner with you and continuing this important
work thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon jessica saco on behalf of children now my thanks to president darling hammon and vice
president glover woods for their comments immediately preceding this public comment period
school climate happens at the school level we know from a review of the california healthy
kids survey data that there are often that there are often differences in how demographically
similar students experience school compared to students and other demographically similar
groups we also know that schools within a district may have dramatically different climates
and positive school climates can improve student outcomes it is for these reasons i urge the board
to consider how our state's accountability system can better support the reporting of school climate
data at both the school and student group level additionally i urge the board to reflect on the
lack of accountability and transparency that has been built into our local indicators model
i refer you to both the equity coalition and alliance for student success letters regarding
this item for our full comments thank you thank you next caller please state your name and
affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon i'm sarah lillis executive director teach bus california we're pleased
that the board is spending this afternoon considering the importance of school climate
for student success and well-being no one could have made it clear how important positive and
culturally affirming school climate is than the students you heard from today well we're happy
that so many schools and aliases have taken advantage of the resources of the ccsd
we believe there's more the state can do to ensure that we're prioritizing positive school
climate for all students we'd hope that the other school climate related allocation from the budget
trailer bowl would have moved us forward to enable statewide comparable data by identifying
standardized items of school climate surveys and we understand that at the level of the allocation
150 000 there were no applicants to do this work without that we do not have a view of the disparate
experiences between schools lea and students moreover the state cannot ensure that schools
and districts were struggling to provide the positive faith and culturally affirming school
climate will help get the help they need while the support of west bed is providing represents
progress we do not know if it's reaching the communities that need it most we recommend the
state board direct cde staff to provide guidance for how to move forward collecting and reporting
more consistent school climate survey data across the state thank you thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon this is liz gian with public advocates also for the lcff equity coalition
the good work presented today by west ed and san diego are commendable i was happy to hear that
despite different surveys there are similar questions that provide valid and reliable data
but are they comparable can we require lea to take some action about it the flexibet will
be currently allowed to lea's on this indicator is a real disservice to students and their families
and advocates as we try to improve students experiences the dashboard report is not an
indication of school climate good poor or indifferent it is merely an indicator that
the lea administered a survey at least every other year in at least one grade within a grade
band and reported something about it we note that the dashboard report is simply a report that the
la took these steps but not that they did anything about it vice president clover wood underscored
that lea should be required to report survey results by student groups and overall score for
all students lea should be required to include analyses of items on their surveys they are not
required to do this i echo the comments by sarah lillas just before me that the state can do better
and we need to move forward to collect and report more consistent school climate survey data thank
you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now good afternoon chair linda darling hammon state board of education members
my name is caitlin young with the association of california school administrators actually
understands and values the importance of school climate for student success and well-being our
school and district leaders rely on data from local school climate surveys to drive improvement
efforts to ensure our schools are positive environments that support and embrace all of
our students staff and families whether a minimum requirement that applies to the school's climate
survey la's rely on the flexibility provided so that they can determine what survey instrument
and the frequency that is most appropriate and useful for their school communities this flexibility
is important given the diversity of the students we serve so that the local surveys are responsive
to our family's cultures languages experiences and other local factors acts also appreciates the
work of cde and west ed to provide training for lea on interpreting local school climate survey
data this will help our lea's to be more adept and effective in understanding student voices and
translating that feedback into needed school improvement efforts thank you thank you next
caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon president darlin hammond vice president glover woods and members of the board
this is derek lennox with the california county superintendent on behalf of the 58 county
superintendents of schools we agree a positive school climate is essential to student success
and collecting these data serve as an important baseline for youth voice to guide the continuous
improvement plans such as the l cap throughout the state we see lea's utilizing a wide variety
of tools to evaluate and improve the unique school climates of the district school site and
classroom levels our lea's use these data to identify and address areas needed to ensure every
student feels safe and connected to their daily learning environment we've provided more specific
examples in our letter to the board and would welcome opportunities to continue the discussion
on the ways our lea's use school climate data to drive their equity work and continuous
improvement plan thank you thank you that concludes public comment for item number five
right thank you so much i really appreciate all of the comments from all of the callers
really an important topic and i now want to open this up for board discussion
uh and i know that vice president glover woods you are reserving a little bit of time for some
more comments there but let's see if there are others who also want to get in the mix
member mcclellan we'll start with you thank you and i really appreciate this topic also on school
climate especially as we struggle to come out of the pandemic and i heard one of the presenters
talking about the covid related impacts on some of the data i was curious about additional impacts
on our current data but it's such an important topic when we hear about substance abuse and
school violence and all the things that are related to this topic with school with student behavior
um i'm i'm hoping and i'm sure it's there somewhere that we're connecting
this effort with the community schools development you know as schools apply for and
plan the community school efforts and then i'm sure it's there also somewhere about best practices
as we go through the various lea's and individual schools that we see best practices are promising
practices where it could be a hotline or other efforts where we're monitoring school the students
and and and their wellness and that there's a place where those who aren't far far along in
this process can go to and see those best practices to try to model after those so
i'm hoping there's an effort there there probably is but thank you for this topic and and i really
appreciate it thank you thank you so much and just a note that in the legislation for community
schools it does explicitly call on those schools to work around social emotional learning and
school climate and restorative practices so to your point we hope that that will actually be
a very explicit part of the school development process um campatiel brunson
uh i also just wanted to thank you all for the presentation it was both sobering but also just
incredibly powerful i i wanted to ask if you could talk a little bit more about how data collection
looks in the younger grades in the sort of tk kn1 before kids are necessarily quite ready for
surveys and how parent engagement works for sort of doing the data collection side of the work
and then also if there are any if you could describe some of the
practices that are emerging in terms of social emotional learning in those younger years
uh i guess this could go in part to our wested team but um i'll leave it to the folks at the
podium to figure out who should start us off on that
do we have someone who can tackle that question of early learning
yes we do we're talking about that now for you all we were looking at the item as well
item as well and so to answer the question we know that we are collecting the data in k5
i can speak to my practice in the past where students were asked questions
and the teachers were helping the younger children out but again it does depend on the district
i can turn it over to tom to see if they have any information too about what they've seen from the
lea's terrific thank you thank you i i don't i don't have a whole lot uh more to share except
that there's um there are elementary versions of these of these surveys the chks is administered
uh there's an elementary version of that survey um unfortunately i don't quite have like the
numbers of participation it is less than uh the surveys surveys are administered less frequently
in the elementary schools than in the secondary schools
but you know i could provide that information at a later time if needed okay that'd be great yeah
i've actually seen some of this in action maybe some of you have and we have a second grade
teacher who might be able to chime in on this but sometimes the teachers are reading the questions
and there are little icons for students to recognize the way in which they might answer
um member lewis and then member alken uh member glover woods and uh member arusco gonzales if
you'd like to chime in on how this happens for your second grade or so would be very useful also
member lewis okay thank you uh president darling ham and thank you um to all of you who uh presented
that report and it was really great hearing all that information from san diego unified and how
you're using the data i think it's a great example uh of good use of the data and putting it
into practice and making uh the school environment uh safe and welcoming and conducive for learning
for for our students just a just a couple of things uh to point out and then a question
um vice president glover woods has already brought up the the concern about the disaggregation
of data but within the calls to and within some of the correspondence we had there was
a concern about the development of standardized questions that could be used across districts
across the state so that there's some type of i think it the goal is accountability and making
sure that the that districts are using the surveys to move things in a positive direction
for students and student outcomes and i just if i could get information about the the 150 000 that
was designated it seemed like that there was a process to begin doing that if that's correct
standardizing a few items to go on the survey because that would also take care of some of
the concerns that some of the district leaders have about keeping flexibility within the survey
so that they can make the survey you know contain questions that they feel they're important to
their district but also giving some standardized questions for everyone to use to be able to
disaggregate the data by student groups and and also by race ethnicity gender lgbtq all of those
things to see how students are really faring on our camp campuses and get an honest view of what
schools and districts need to do to to make them feel comfortable so is that work um what um
someone mentioned that they couldn't find someone to initiate that project if that's so is there a
plan b for that and um the plans for moving forward with that i know that's a lot but
yeah hopefully okay let's answer that maybe about the the process for the developing the
standardized questions that could be used maybe that question first and then i guess my other
question is you know as a board do would we have the leverage what is our leverage to be able to
make the requirements for disaggregating the data if that's a direction that we
we choose to go to starting discussion about those questions and how to assist districts in in
making more use of the data because it sounds like a lot of districts are they're they're trying to
use the data to inform decisions but to make the process even better to make sure that
um all districts are using the data effectively right and just on that second question this is a
matter that is in the board's purview so we will be considering those questions as a board
and okay to william he may want to say something about um your first question which was
what happened when we did not find someone to respond to the
uh the earlier rfp william did you want to tackle any of that right now yes absolutely thank you
president darlingham and to you member louis i do have hilva chan here who's from the whole
child division that was a question that we did discuss and so she can give us a brief
update and information on that okay thank you good afternoon i just want to provide a quick
update so the cde did issue a rfp back in october 2021 trying to find a contractor to provide
the study trying to conduct a study on the sanitized school comments survey so we only
received one application and the applicant later withdrew the application because they couldn't
find a subcontractor to conduct some psychometric studies so we're unable to implement this and the
money went back to the uh what we reverted back so let me just say that um there's still an interest
in our uh board consideration of these questions about whether and how we might want to move ahead
with you know a variety of elements here you know about periodicity the frequency of the survey the
ways in which it might be analyzed and the extent to which there might be some standards questions
so those are not off the table they are on our table and we will be you know thinking about these
things over this month and coming months um member oaken thank you thank you um i i just want to first
say um in in a way of saying thank you to our presenters that this is yet another um presentation
at the state board where i'm just blown away by the expert support and work across the state
and one of the things that's become really clear to me in and having the privilege to sit in this
seat is um there's so much good work and we can learn so much from each other and so for example
the california center for school climate i'm going to be on your website myself
and looking into your resources and san diego unified thank you so much for those very specific
examples of the way you use school climate data to make changes at both the the sort of micro level
teachers in the hallways to the macro level staffing and systems of support and that really
kind of gets to the the heart of my comment which is i think we all know this but one of the really
important reasons that this school climate data matters is because it can help us make changes
at both the the micro and the macro level and i think that some of the tension that we're hearing
between wanting systemized questions or standard questions and wanting schools to be able to
design questions or or surveys at the site level speaks to that because if you want to if you want
to make change at the system level we need to be able to see some standardized results and if you
want to be able to implement change at the very local level you need data that responds to the
work you're doing and so i appreciate sort of both sets of priorities and i am excited i'm looking
forward to the conversations where we as a board try and figure out how to balance both of those
needs in this with this data because as vice president Glover would said i believe how students
feel at school their sense of safety their sense of connection their sense of inclusion
if they believe that people there think they matter and can be successful is the most important
predeterminate for academic success they just go hand in hand and so
i look forward to more of this conversation and i thank everybody for the good work they're doing
terrific thank you i have member arusco gonzalez member yoshi mater tari and member glover woods
cued up member arusco gonzalez thank you again for the presentation and as a second grade teacher
you know i always think of you know when students attend school with a positive school climate they
feel valued and they feel seen and it's that connectiveness as a second grade teacher i
always cultivate classroom chemistry and community by fostering authentic relationships
understanding how they where and how they come from and when that starts is usually in our morning
meetings that's a great opportunity for learners to develop empathy as they learn to listen with
understanding and consider how to best respond to their peers we also partner up and we engage in
conversations to just discuss our everyday needs and how to navigate relationships sometimes we just
shine a light on students we on students often teachers overlook certain students so
i make it a point to have a few students written down on my lesson plans to say kind of a check
in how they're doing we even develop some collaboration strategies and discussion points
sentence frames and so forth just to have those critical conversations and give them an opportunity
to have an engagement and i always say honor student experience reflect on it have time to
structure inquiry and dialogue in the class as a school wide and as a district we we definitely
do that we do sometimes our administration pops into our morning meetings even at the district
level we will have superintendents and and so forth come in and celebrate community at our schools
and and again it's children feeling connected to school and i recently read an article about how
because i have a high schooler about how he can be more successful in school and it's the more
he participates i think of those 40 developmental assets which one of them is to be to feel connected
and to feel that they're an active participant at schools and he's in sports and in clubs and i feel
that that's just the beginning of foundation to feel successful and to be seen and feel motivated
to participate in a community so those are awesome ideas but i know as a second grade teacher it's
about inclusivity being seen and heard you know i think that giving children opportunities to
constantly throughout the day to have dialogue and with our peers and with our teachers
and hopefully those kinds of opportunities show up in the ways that students both respond in the
classroom and provide information on these kinds of surveys thank you so much back to oh can i do
that just with that with assessments i just made a connection about that because what i really
deeply love about performance tasks and when we're having those conversations around that is that
is that with the opportunity that the students have to explain their thought process that's also
part of their learning so it's all connected today so thank you. Member Yoshima Otori and then
member Glover Woods and then we'll come back around to member Rodriguez. Thank you and thank
you again for this presentation particularly i think what we know and what we're still learning
about the neuroscience piece what everything i'm reading suggests that school climate indicators
may in fact have more impact on the other dashboard indicators than we commonly express
and commonly talk about and so that being said i imagine there's a way to move the process forward
perhaps in a both and way right which both identify as a subset of standard items
particularly because i think that uniquely positions indicator six to have across the
district conversations and across district conversations and use it as an improvement tool
not just within one LEA and and i think we can do that there's a way to do that in terms of
change management that still honors stakeholder input maintains options for multiple measure data
and also provides a solution that honors the LEA's options to address local needs
so i'm confident that there's a way through that and i'm excited to learn more and be a part of
that and lastly i just wanted to second what vice president Glover Woods mentioned about
disaggregated data i think there's great importance in being able to drill down
in the data because the action steps taken could be very different depending on what that data
suggests yes thank you so much member Glover Woods then we'll have member Rodriguez and member
Escobedo thank you and just to continue along with the conversation and the recognition that
we know students different students experience school in different ways whether it be our intent
or not that does happen and when i think about our african-american student group our lgbtq plus
student community newcomers and those who are english learners especially english learners
that are at the earlier levels of english language proficiency their experiences in school can look
very different from the experiences of others and just as i reflect on the phenomenal students we
had an opportunity to hear from today when we were had our earlier item item two and many of
the students we have opportunity to hear from when we have we had the student community group it
wasn't the student community group but the students that spoke with us when we were appointing our
student board member and things of that sort we have students that are having some phenomenal
experiences on our campuses and again the reality is we have some students who are not
and one of the key ways for us to get to who those students are and how we can best support
those students and students overall is through that disaggregation of data as a practitioner my
thought was okay maybe the data is just way too difficult to disaggregate because i do realize
at the lea level it's sounds all well and good to say okay you should do this but actually being
able to do it can always meet with some challenges but i was encouraged by i believe it was tom that
said the instruments that are being used by the majority of our leas already have that disaggregation
capability built in so one of the things that i really am encouraging us and would like to see
us engage in more conversation about in the future is how we can ensure that the school climate data
is disaggregated by student group and shared and reported in that way one of the other reasons
for that is how the community can also be partners in this work of creating positive
experiences for students on campuses we have community groups we have our parents we have
all types of people in groups and organizations that want to help so that students experience
school well and are able to be successful having this data disaggregated in such a way that can
help point to ways we can partner point to actions that can be implemented to make school experience
a more positive one for our students is something that i think is very important for us to do and i
do hope we'll be engaging in additional conversation in future meetings thank you
thank you um member rodriguez and member escapado naomi did i just see your hands start to go up
no okay just ruminating okay uh member rodriguez thank you president darling hamond and um thank
you to our presenters the this has uh been a very rich conversation and uh school climate is
definitely a uh an important factor in student success without a doubt um and i'm very proud of
the steps that my school district has taken with regard to the surveys um you know we've uh they
the data is shared with us at staff meetings so we're able to think about and place
where our students are right how many students are have considered suicide have considered
have gotten uh close right you know have gone beyond thinking about it and actually have attempted
it and it really brings a reality to us of who we have in our classrooms right and the emotional
issues that our students are facing um issues of identity ethnic identity gender identity um
and it creates you know that empathy that um member arrozco was talking about right you know
it brings it to us so that we can see what we're going to do with that information um as one of
the members of the sel team at my school we definitely use this information when we're
planning activities for our students um and we have a counselor for a day at our school
so any child that needs to go speak to somebody um they the counselor is available to them and
our counselors have been trained in crisis intervention so they have tools to find out
at what level a student is facing crisis um and then they can refer to we also have a mental health
specialist um that is available to students in crisis so all of this is because of these surveys
and because of this information and i'd also like to echo the um the desire to see this this data
disaggregated right and to be able to break it down into the student population that perhaps is
facing more crises um and i'd also like to add another aspect of school climate which is
um how that relates to teachers uh right you know as as teachers we're working with our students on
a daily basis and school climate also affects us certain decisions that are made um that are
that are leadership made structural decisions and um perhaps there's a way to incorporate
our voice as well i noticed that you know in the two qr codes that were shared
one of them the cal schools which is a cd website um it has a school staff survey
but it's you know and maybe that's a good place to start um but there are other issues about you
know how decisions are made what the culture of schools are because that uh works that goes to
teacher satisfaction which goes to teacher burnout how long teachers stay in the classroom
right all of these issues that we're dealing with at another level and i'd like to quote an article
um by matthew craft and grace falcon of brown university why school climate matters for teachers
and students um school climates consist of a constellation of organizational features
that shape teachers and students experiences strong school climates are characterized by
supportive leadership teacher collaboration high expectation for students and a collective
commitment to support student learning teaching is a social career and the relationships that
teachers have with those who support their work in the classroom administrators and colleagues
heavily influence teacher satisfaction and success so it's just something that i'd like
to put out there uh for the future to start thinking about adding um a teacher survey as
well uh down the line thank you terrific um member escapado dr hammond hided said it so
eloquently about the color you know what school climate is a whole interaction of not just students
among each other but the adults and the students which i would also include parents and i'm not
suggesting for this to be a state level uh luck but perhaps resources that can be provided to
districts that they can include in their l cap to measure right climate that affects parents as well
as our teachers and classified as well so i i think uh you know it's a very complex issue and
the resources that we provide to our districts can help them understand what climate is all about
so thank you trustee haydee for sharing that as well
member porter thank you so the conversation i think especially between
members about empathy and students kind of feeling connected to staff kind of sparked
what i've seen very successfully implemented in the districts and schools that i've talked to
and that's having student advisory groups that meet regularly whether it be with principals with
superintendents on the school or district-wide level and i think this is a great way for students
to directly engage with their principals with their classified staff and to really feel
supported at school because it's one thing to kind of have these surveys once a year but it's
another thing to kind of directly gauge um kind of how students are doing and to have an ongoing
conversation so that's just something that i would encourage principals superintendents to consider is
having student advisory groups to kind of continue that ongoing conversation about
what school climate looks like as it's constantly changing throughout the year
terrific yeah i think we're getting really down into the roots of the needs in the schools that
are trying to be responsive to students you know we inherited a factory model 100 years ago and
we've been trying to make it work for relationships for a long time and some of the changes like what
you call for member porter around advisory groups that you know give a regular opportunity for a
family group and social emotional supports in schools is one of the kinds of elements that
some schools have undertaken that allow us to go beyond measuring climate but actually building
the kind of climate for concern and caring that we need so i'm really in this conversation just
proud to be part of this group of board members and really benefited so much from the presentations
i want to note that our on our dashboard currently you know we have a measure on engagement of
suspension rates which is intended to incentivize schools to reduce exclusion as a response to
students and to increase inclusion but there's a lot more that one has to do than simply not
suspend students you have to create an environment in which there are alternatives to exclusion in
which there is community building which there's the building of opportunities for conflict
resolution and community and and support and a lot of schools have been doing that and that
shows up in their school climate indicators those that have been putting in place things like
advisories and other support mechanisms for relationships restorative practices which
include community circles kind of like the morning meeting that you would see in elementary school
that you know include the opportunities for conflict resolution for you know students to be
in a conversation with each other about how not to harm each other and how to be supportive of
each other on a regular basis are really important and there's some evidence coming out some of it
very recent that when those practices are in place many of them measured through the set of
items on the healthy kids survey you see gains in achievement you see reductions in exclusion and
just disparate discipline which often is discriminatory by race you see reductions in
mental health suicidal ideation and anxiety and depression so we know something about the
practices that really do make a difference in achievement attendance and self and well-being
all of which also as member rodriguez said also supports educators in being better connected and
supported and and having well-being so i think you know we see the value of these surveys those
that are using them regularly and disaggregating them and really building them into a continuous
improvement process are getting the benefits their students and their educators are getting
the benefits of that so i hope that when we come back in march i guess is our next opportunity
and we see how many districts are already benefiting from this that we could ask the
cde to bring an item in march that looks at these questions of the frequency of the survey
the ways in which we have expectations in the self-reflection tool for how those surveys might
be analyzed and used and whether there is a possibility for some thoughtfully selected
common items that would as a member all can put it allow for the flexibility of you know local
engagement around the improvement process and a set of items but also
allow for some comparison across schools and districts i hope we will be able then to carry
this conversation forward at that time i also just want to note that there are a number of
states that do include teacher surveys and so i think that's a whole nother conversation
of educator and staff surveys that can augment what we learn from students in ways to help us
build a healthy environment for everyone so something to put in the bicycle parking lot
for the you know for a future opportunity to discuss as well this is an information item it
was obviously a rich item and we will return to some of these issues very soon and now we
have earned another 15 minute break so it is about 1 40 we'll see you back at 1 55
remember not to leave the meeting just turn off your mic and your camera
welcome back and to establish our quorum i'm going to ask brooks to call the roll welcome back
member yosemite tauri here member rodriguez here member porter here member patillo brownston
here member roscoe gonzalez here we don't know what that was uh remember welcome here member
mcquillin here number lewis here vice president clever woods here number escapado here president
darlin hammond here everyone's present all right so now we're going to take up the regular consent
items which are six through nine i understand that member yosemite tauri needs to recuse herself
from this vote you can do that by turning off your camera and microphone member yosemite tauri and
stay close to your computer so we can get you back after the vote members of the public wishing to
provide comment on consent items six through nine may do so by calling the telephone number
using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now
so we're going to give a moment of wait time in case there are any public comments
all right do we have anyone calling in uh there are current oh uh there is one person in the queue
for public comment i will open the phone line now all right thank you good afternoon please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon uh this is liz gian with public advocates also for the lcff equity coalition
regarding item a the board is required under federal law to to approve the school site
improvement plans these are the comprehensive support and improvement schools we repeat our
strong concern as we have every year that we don't think you're doing a good enough job in
overseeing the approval of the school site plans these schools represent the most tenuous school
sites in the state and they're on the csi list in part because they haven't received the attention
they need or oversight from their lea the way the department presents them to you is that the
counties have approved the l caps which are supposed to indicate that these plans have
been looked at but we don't think that's very comprehensive and we don't think that's good
enough we think that there's really no external state educational agency actually reviewing
csi plans and we don't think the federal law requires and it looks like we have
one more caller um please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now good afternoon jessica saco on behalf of children now the comprehensive
support and improvement schools are our schools with the lowest five percent of performance across
multiple state indicators these schools need to make significant improvements and that starts
with having a local plan to lead their change process you as a board member are being asked
to approve on a board consent item without discussion a set of school level improvement
plans for these schools without any external entity reviewing these plans we believe that this
is an insufficient level of review of our most at-need schools we encourage the board to schedule
a deeper conversation on this issue and identify how some entity in the broader system of support
could provide support for these schools by reviewing their plans and making recommendations
to the board on whether a csi plan should or should not be approved i refer you to both the
equity coalition and alliance for student success letters regarding this item for our full comment
thank you thank you and that concludes public comment for the regular consent items uh oh six
through nine
okay um given that there's no further public comment i'll ask for a motion on consent items six through nine
member olken move sure yeah uh and is there a second second thank you
we'll now hold a roll call vote brooks please call the roll member yosemite tauri
she's recused thank you it's just habit now uh member rodriguez yes member porter yes
member patillo bronson yes member roscoe gonzalez yes member olken yes member mcquillan
aye member lewis yes let's present glubber woods yes member escapetto yes president
darlin hammond yes the motion carries all right thank you very much and we need member yoshimoto
tauri back now there she is okay um item five is the developments in the expansion of transitional
kindergarten update on the universal pre-k and the pre-k to third grade alignment this is exciting
for us because it's one of our first opportunities to hear how things are going with the scaling up
of universal pre-k there is no recommended action at this time before we start the presentation i
just like to help frame the discussion a little bit the adoption of universal pre-k by the
legislature and the governor expands access to preschool education in a way that is really
unmatched in scope and quality by any other state in the country you heard reference to that earlier
today at this historic moment we need to help local education agencies focus on offering pre-k
programs that are designed to maximize opportunities for developmental growth and encouragement to give
every child a strong start in school and in reviewing the public comment that we've received
to date on this item i'm reminded that it's not always clear which entities have decision-making
authority for early education programs the purview of the state board of education is limited
to grades k-12 which includes transitional kindergarten as the first year of a two-year
kindergarten program so the california state preschool program and the other early education
programs are under the authority of the state superintendent the department of social services
the legislature and in the case of head start the federal government so there's a multifaceted
governance structure of which we are a part for the part of for the transitional kindergarten
element additionally the state board cannot appropriate state funds so we have had some
comments about places where funding may be needed we do however have responsibility to set policies
for important tk through 12 programmatic components related to curriculum instruction and assessment
for determining the accountability measures and data collection for k-12 and this item will provide
some baseline information for our continuing engagement in this space we look forward to
continuing to work with the interest holders the department the legislature and the administration
to fully realize the promise of universal pre-kindergarten and this item will be presented
by sarah neville morgan and steven profiter of the cde sarah and steven please begin
thank you so much board chair darling hammon we really are really excited about being before the
board today to do this historic item so my name is sarah neville morgan and i'm a deputy superintendent
of public instruction in the opportunities for all branch at the california department of education
under state superintendent tony thurmond i'm joined today by steven profiter the director
of the early education division and we're really excited to share all the work we've been doing on
upk including the expansion of tk before we dive in we wanted to provide some level setting on what
we mean by upk or universal pre-kindergarten upk is the expansion of the state's mixed delivery
system to meet the early education needs of three and four-year-old children and their families
in california we're relying heavily on transitional kindergarten or tk which will be the only program
universally available to all four-year-old children by 2025-26 upk is an essential part
of transforming california's educational system and giving every student in california a great
start the creation of upk in california was recommended by california's master plan for
early learning and care or our master plan which sets force the goals for the administration to
establish and support upk the state board of education plays an important role in upk
because the board has oversight over transitional kindergarten as board member darling hammon laid
out as this is an important informational item and does not provide any recommendations the
information we are sharing with you today is intended to ensure you are fully informed about
the status of tk and how it fits into a bigger picture of upk in this presentation we will
highlight curriculum assessment instructional materials and workforce requirements and
professional learning alignment as those areas may come before the board either as tk specific items
or in the context of other information and action items we also would like to recognize some
components covered in this item are outside of the board's authority for example investments in
certain program requirements like adult child ratios among other things however we have included
them to provide context for the system in which the board's responsibility lies
california's master plan laid out a roadmap for ensuring california's children thrive in their
early years and explicitly called for promoting school readiness and increasing long-term school
performance and educational outcomes by expanding access over time to achieve one year of free
universally available and inclusive pre-k for all four-year-old children and expanding targeted
access or targeted universalism to an additional year of publicly funded pre-k for all three-year-old
children who are income eligible and well as children with disabilities through upk's mixed
delivery system we will achieve universal access to tk for four-year-old children and have also a
variety of other pre-k options within the system which will go over in upcoming slides and those
will serve a growing number of three-year-old children in high quality pre-k programs as well
as some four-year-olds whose families still choose that as their parent option these not only will
equip our children with school readiness and healthy development but also prepare them for
lifelong success i also want to elevate the master plan's recommendation to support children's
learning and development by investing in our early educator workforce we all know how critical the
teachers are including providing ongoing opportunities for professional development
creating new workforce pathways and accelerating and enhancing existing ones and creating a pre-k
to third grade ece teaching credential and implementing program standards that support
educators to nurture children's learning and development as we work to follow the road map
set out in the master plan we want like to emphasize that upk is also a key part of the
state superintendent's larger transforming schools initiative implementation of upk alongside other
investments in community schools professional learning anti-bias education mental health programs
expanded learning programs and universal meals all of those are interconnected and present a
historic opportunity to transform California schools into safe havens that support and nurture
the whole child we're really excited about the interconnected nature of these investments
and the opportunity to leverage them to build a preschool to third grade or p3 alignment in our
system this historical universal approach to education is an opportunity for California to
rethink or reimagine our educational system as one that brings equity to all students and families
and also provides great opportunities for teachers and those interested in becoming teachers
from those serving the littles all the way up through our pipeline well tk is the only
universally available program we do want to highlight that it's part of a broader diverse
and incredibly valuable system of programs serving our youngest learners upk brings together tk as
well as all of our existing California state preschool programs and federal early education
programs as well as private child care family child care and expanded learning opportunities
including before and after school programs that help achieve a full day full year support
for families and ensure a preschool learning experience
upk is backed by an abundance of research demonstrating the positive benefits of the
pre-kindergarten year prior to k-12 in both short and long-term outcomes the most consistently
identified effects are on academic achievement at the end of pre-k and the beginning of k
children who participate in quality pre-k have increased school readiness in both academic and
in social emotional skills children who were able to attend two years of the abbott preschool
program in new jersey had even stronger gains than those who attended for one year importantly
much of the research on the early and targeted pre-k programs have indicated the strongest
effects are for african-american and hispanic latino children multilingual learners and children
from low-income families when they have access to quality programs in addition long-time evidence
from the abbasidarian the chicago parent center and new ones from abbott new jersey studies
indicate that children who attend pre-k experience lower rates of special education placement
and grade retention in elementary school increased school readiness really lays that foundation for
later academic success as well both the abbott preschool programs in new jersey and the total
oklahoma program finds that from third grade through high school children who attended the
pre-k programs and who continue to have quality learning experiences have higher scores on
standardized tests in math language and literacy in the perry chicago parent centers and tulsa
children who attend pre-k also have been found to have a higher likelihood of graduating from high
school finally research from the early preschool programs abbasidarian perry and the child parent
um child parent center and the tulsa oklahoma pre-k programs have shown strong positive effects
for pre-k attendees in adulthood in tulsa after they turned 18 children who attended their
school-based pre-k programs had both increased rates of voter registration and voting in elections
showing stronger civic engagement that was one of those novel found findings that we just learned
about the abbasidarian chicago parent center and tulsa oklahoma programs all identified higher rates
of college enrollment or attendance for those who attended the pre-k programs in tulsa pre-k
participants from all racial ethnic groups at higher rates of two-year college enrollment and
african-american and hispanic participants at higher rates of four-year college enrollment as well
finally there is evidence of positive effects on adult health from the earliest to pair programs
among the abbasidarian perry preschool and chicago parent centers they found lower rates of teen
pregnancy hypertension diabetes and depressive symptoms in children who attended quality pre-k
programs so a lot there in the rich robust research world moving into our alignment between systems
upk also serves as a bridge between the early learning and care systems and the tk through 12
grade or tk to 12 system we know a strong start in pre-k is only beneficial if it is sustained
and we can't deliver on that promise of upk without the alignment and support of the early
grades reinforcing and building off and accelerating children's previous pre-k experiences
because of this the cde has also developed a preschool to third grade or p to three vision
to set forth the intention and goals of upk to thrive in that broader p to three system
the graphic you see right now comes from the national p3 center which is supporting us to
create a strategic plan around p3 our cde mission statement for p3 is that all children have a strong
and early start to inclusive education through high quality joyful rigorous developmentally
informed and coherent preschool through third grade learning opportunities to ensure they
thrive in school and and in life and are college and career ready the goals of this alignment
initiative are to ensure first that we give all children a strong start for providing them that
access with at least one year and for that promise for growing at least two years of high
quality early education experiences two we ensure all pk to three elementary teachers
are equipped to support and sustain learning by enhancing the teacher's competencies to optimally
support child learning and development and implement instructional practices to sustain
children's learning from k to three three we equip education leaders at the county
district and school level so they understand the value of early education and support strong
transitions for student success and enact organizational strategies to support meaningful
alignment across that p to three learning continuum and lastly to empower and support families so they
have meaningful engagement opportunities across the early years in pk and in the k to three
settings that encourage them to play an active role as advocates and resources to facilitate the
growth and development of young learners throughout this presentation you'll hear us making references
to p3 and demonstrate how children and our young students can reap the benefits of tk and upk
within a p3 system that ensures developmentally supportive instruction and a focus on the whole
child i'm now going to pass this over to steve who's going to dive into some of the key elements
from the item including tk expansion and rollout over to you steve thank you sarah i'll start with
some context on how tk was created and expanded so first the kindergarten readiness act of 2010
changed the last eligible birth date for kindergarten from december 2nd to september 1st
so that all children would enter kindergarten as slightly older five-year-olds by 2014
to support families whose kindergarten entry would be delayed by this change it established
transitional kindergarten as the first year of a two-year kindergarten program
the 2015-16 budget introduced early admittance tk as an option for children with birthdays between
december 2nd and the end of the school year further bolstering access for children in this
age range under this option district districts can choose to serve children in this birthday
range but do not generate funding through average daily attendance for the child until their fifth
birthday the 2021-22 budget introduced a timeline to achieve universal tk for all four-year-old
children by 25-26 as well as new tk requirements and provided funding for upk planning and
implementation and an increase in funding for expanded learning through the expanded learning
opportunities program to support access to full daycare in the current year's budget 2022-23
it provided additional lcff funding for tk and established fiscal penalties related to tk average
class size and teacher to child ratio school districts and charter schools with tk receive an
add-on to the lcff entitlement for the cost of an additional adult to meet the one to 12 ratio
in tk classrooms the add-on amount is equal to the tk add-on rate 2813 dollars multiplied by the
lea's current year tk average daily attendance fiscal penalties applied to any school district
or charter school with tk enrollment not meeting the requirements for average class size adult to
child ratio or teacher qualifications beginning in 2020-23-24 by 25-26 we will achieve the full
implementation of universal tk meaning all children turning four by september 1 will be eligible
this table included on page 12 of the item shows a timeline for changes in age eligibility for etk
or early admittance tk and tk during tk expansion showing that two months of birth dates for
children turning five are added in each year starting this year up until full implementation
in 25-26 when all children turning four by september 1 will be eligible
so what does expansion of tk mean for projected enrollment the learning policy institute has
projected that tk enrollment will more than triple by 25-26 and serve approximately 70 percent
of the eligible four-year-old population in california at full implementation
so what is tk implementation looking like right now we've covered all of the areas of tk
implementation listed here in detail in the item so today we'll highlight areas that are most
relevant to the board's purview and indicated in green on the slide and those are access curriculum
assessment workforce qualifications and professional learning the two workforce areas are primarily
under the purview of the commission on teacher credentialing but are important to understanding
the implementation of tk in the past two years we've witnessed historic investments to support
the expansion of tk and the planning and implementation of upk these include the upk
planning and implementation grant which supports lea's to expand access to upk through creating
or expanding cspp or tk programs or establishing or strengthening partnerships with other upk
programs in the lea's area the early education teacher development grant which supports the
workforce by funding lea's to increase the number of early educators and increase specific
competencies for tk kindergarten and cspp educators the upk mixed delivery planning grant
which provides counties with funding to support relationship building among lea's
the county office of education the local planning council and the local child care
resource and referral to expand access to the mixed delivery system for three and four-year-old
children and increase inclusion of children with disabilities our partners at the california
commission on teacher credentialing have developed a pk3 early childhood specialist teaching
credential and related to this is a charge from the 2022-23 budget to establish a upk mixed
delivery quality and access work group that m aims to identify best practices for increasing
access to high quality universal preschool programs and update preschool standards to
reflect these practices so overall the cde has seized on the historic opportunity these
investments have created and is providing extensive support guidance and resources
including the creation of robust guidance documents to accompany the upk planning and
implementation grants hosting regular upk webinars and office hours the creation of an
faq page the launch of the california upk and p3 group on the california educators together
platform a p3 alignment webinar series and a upk communications campaign including multilingual
resources for family and community engagement that emphasize the benefits of upk and tk for
children and families and empower parents to make informed choices
to support implementation we have in partnership with the commission on teacher credentialing
been using a constellation approach to guide all of our upk implementation and p3 alignment
efforts the goal of this approach is to ensure that multiple sectors and levels within the state
are working together to develop guidance to the field on tk implementation including local
implementers researchers workforce communications and support systems partners among others
these partners work together in the five thematic constellations you see in this diagram
including local implementation and promising practices research workforce development upk
support systems and partnerships communications and strategy the state leadership team and the
upk p3 kitchen cabinet with representation from early childhood education organizations
and state agency partners are the leadership teams setting strategic directions and aligning
the constellation to meet overarching goals now i'll dive into sharing some successes
related to access to tk we want to emphasize that when we talk about access access that while
districts that serve kindergartners must offer tk tk is not mandatory for children to enroll
and families will continue to be able to choose the program that best fits their needs additionally
we want to note that this information is intended to provide context as these requirements are
statutory and outside of the board's preview now while data from 2122 and the current school year
isn't quite available yet the lpi projects that in this first year of expansion 2223
137 000 children or 30 30 percent of all four-year-old children will be certain tk
every lea expected to have tk enrollment received upk planning and implementation grant funds
and as part of that we're required to present a plan for upk to their local governing board by
june 30 2022 and submit their plans for upk to the cde in a survey in fall 2022 we have some
useful data from the survey on the progress towards achieving universal access to tk
and overall upk implementation with support from lpi we've analyzed a sample which represents the
majority of these responses including 829 school districts and 594 charter schools
which is about 97 percent of districts and 85 percent of charters with expected tk enrollment
and 62 percent of all districts and charters in california in addition to these all 58 county
offices of education responded to the survey you can refer to attachments three and four of the item
for the full survey results so data from the surveys show the majority of lea's report
they intend to offer tk at all sites which would support access to being to be evenly distributed
geographically they plan to or are considering offering etk or early admittance tk which would
accelerate expansion beyond the statutory timeline and they intend to offer full-day tk
which would support families and having the coverage they need additionally 79 percent of
lea's plan to combine tk with expanded learning programs and 20 with the california state preschool
program to achieve a full day increased access to tk will have a huge impact on families across
california especially for the 250 000 children eligible for the california state preschool
program but unable to enroll due to limited space and also for the families of the 155 000
children that aren't eligible for the california state preschool program
lea's are also planning for how to engage families as tk expands with the most common
strategies including family or parent surveys local control and accountability plan educational
partner input sessions and engaging school site councils i'll now hand this back over to sarah
thanks so much steve we're going to go on to curriculum the curriculum requirement for tk
is to use a modified kindergarten curriculum that is age and developmentally appropriate
it's also the intent of the legislature that tk curriculum be aligned to the california preschool
learning foundations in a survey conducted this fall we found tk programs have interpreted this
language in a tent in a variety of ways before we highlight those results we want to describe
what a developmentally appropriate curriculum might look like as tk curriculum is under the purview of
the board at age four children need a lot of hands-on experiences and movement opportunities
for child-led learning oral language development and peer interaction through play exposure to
interaction through play exposure to key topics in social emotional learning and developing their
executive functioning skills and a scope of learning and sequence and foundational math and
literacy skills these are all components that are based in the science of learning and development
if you walk into a high quality pre-k classroom this might look like less emphasis on workbooks
and a whole group instruction and more time spent in small group instruction to work on
foundational skills these skills are then reinforced during center time and playful
learning where children get to visit a range of centers or stations to apply their learning
experiences to the dramatic play area building areas science exploration art games ongoing
projects and the teachers are able to conduct formative assessments and scaffold the students
learning an effective developmentally supportive curriculum also includes ample time for children
to express their thinking through language this means children are not only listening to books
being read to them but are engaging in discussion and making connections between books and topics
they are learning and curious about as highlighted earlier in our p3 slide this philosophy of learning
is needed across all the early grades especially in the pre-k through third grade space to ensure
learning remains joyful and actively engaging for our youngest learners on page 19 of the item
you'll see a reference to the boston public schools pre-k through second grade curriculum
which is a good exemplar of this philosophy in action and also a public pre-k that has strong
results as we move on to the curriculum approaches the first one that we'll share a little bit about
is the whole child curriculum in a survey distributed this past fall to our p3 lister
including educators and administrators in upa programs we asked the field what curricula they
are currently using for upa and what support they need around curriculum resources presented
here are results from 210 districts and county office administrators 24 school site administrators
and principals and 207 tk teachers a total of just over 450 tk programs were represented
across 305 districts and 53 counties we will walk through some key results on the next few
slides but just wanted to know this is a subsample of tk programs and may not be
representative of the larger tk population second about 14 percent of respondents also did not have
a clear idea of the curriculum used in tk in their district and finally the survey was unable to
ascertain how well a reported curricular approach is actually being implemented
which research demonstrates is the critical component for child outcomes participant responses
were categorized into different curricular approaches for tk the first is what we call
a pre-k comprehensive or whole child curricula circled here these curricula are very popular
in public preschool settings and typically highlight a range of developmental skills in
a play-based frame as you can see in the yellow section 118 or 26 percent of tk sites that
responded reported using a pre-k comprehensive whole child curriculum although this model can
be implemented effectively there are a few cautions to note for strengths this curricular approach
emphasizes play-based learning through child-led centers social emotional learning and developmentally
informed content however they often lack sufficient explicit guidance on a scope and
sequence for instruction of math and literacy skills and there is empirical evidence that
domain specific curricula that target explicit math and literacy skills lead to higher gains
in math and literacy compared to a whole child curricula alone with the largest achievement gaps
observed for math skills in particular moving on we'll go to the second curriculum approach
which is what is most aligned with the boston public schools pre-kindergarten
model that i mentioned just a little bit earlier 50 tk sites are 11 percent of those who completed
the survey are currently using a whole child or social emotional curriculum and a pre-k math and
literacy curriculum that is developmentally appropriate about 10 of our tk sites that
completed the survey are also using this combination approach and are supplementing using district
developed math and literacy units instead of the publisher version so a smaller subset we have the
11 and the 10 again if implemented to fidelity this approach is the most likely to be aligned
with the science of learning and development emphasizing both the whole child and providing
that strong foundation in math and literacy however because a combination of curricula
is required fidelity of implementation can be difficult to achieve and can be more costly as
the teachers may need additional supports moving on to our curriculum approach number three math
and literacy and no explicit focus on social emotional learning this last curriculum approach
runs the risk highest risk of not being developmentally supportive about 90 tk sites
are 20 percent who responded using pre-k math and literacy curriculum or district developed units
in math or literacy with no explicit full child or social emotional learning curriculum supplement
or integration this typically looks like the tk program using a pre-k version of their
kindergarten curriculum but there is no evidence of an explicit social emotional learning focus
or time spent in centers or play domains that are really highlighted in our preschool learning
foundations 10 of the sites reported using the same curriculum they use for kindergarten
and may have mentioned the use of social emotional learning strategies but did not have an
explicit focus on social emotional learning or time dedicated in the day for it well this option
might be the easiest for districts to adopt and use in a tk k combo classroom it's also the least
likely to support the learning needs of young children and less differentiation is practice
and social emotional strategies are robust for example adjusting the curriculum for younger
learners who might not be meeting the kindergarten standards and intentionally
embedding social emotional topics throughout the curriculum as tk continues to expand to
younger and younger four-year-olds we want to ensure curriculum is developmentally supportive
a popular pre-k curriculum approach emphasizes the whole child which highlights how all the
domains of child development are connected and should be valued for example social emotional
development is a large component of expressing language and understanding text and executive
functioning can support math learning and vice versa and the whole child their emotional social
physical and cognitive well-being are all important and of value for the teacher to nurture
overall a whole child approach is promised on the fact that learning depends on the combination of
instructional relational and environmental factors to child experiences along with the
cognitive social and emotional processes that influence one another as they shape the child's
growth and development i will flag that that's a huge component around things like community
schools with tk entering the k-12 system and the creation of a pk to third credential we also have
an opportunity to adopt these practices from the science of learning and development in grades tk
through third for example in our tk curriculum survey school and district administrators and
teacher respondents also listed what supports they would like for curriculum and the top responses
the top response was support for social emotional learning and adopting more play-based approaches
in tk so this is clearly a need and an opportunity to introduce whole child practices
in tk to third more broadly in fact our early learning standards for preschool
in california are based on whole child development the preschool learning foundations which were
created by the cde to set the learning expectations for children ages three to five
serve a similar function as the common core state standards as you'll see detailed in the item the
first volume was released in 2008 the next in 2010 and the third volume in 2012 because of the
emphasis on the whole child several domains of learning are highlighted language and literacy
math science and social sciences but also social emotional development visual and performing arts
physical development and health we are also adding a new domain approaches to learning which
covers children's executive functioning and self-regulation skills the cde also developed
the preschool curriculum frameworks which details how to apply these domains of development to
learning opportunities in the classroom to give you a better look at the format of the preschool
learning foundations the one you see on the screen before you is an example of the number sense domain
in math which details the milestone expected around age four or at the end of the first year
of preschool and at age five or at the end of the second year of preschool or pre-kindergarten
the structures represent a foundation or learning expectation and then examples of what that might
look like in an early learning setting in the 2021 state budget the california department of
education received funding to revise the preschool learning foundations as part of those
revisions we're ensuring the content covered it's inclusive of tk additionally we are hoping to
better align with sub domain categories in the kindergarten common core so that tk teachers can
more easily crosswalk between those two sets of standards another major goal is to include language
that is more inclusive of children with disabilities multilingual learners and capture
the experiences of children from different racial and cultural backgrounds the revision of this
document will be available in late 2023 we also receive funding to extend the preschool learning
foundations to third grade to illustrate the developmental continuum across the preschool
third grade period the plan is to focus on five major domains math language literacy science
social emotional development and approaches to learning teachers will be able to reference this
document to understand what development in these skills looks like across the learning trajectory
as well as having hands-on examples the hope for this resource is to complement the common core
by illustrating how preschool and developmentally supportive practices
based on the science of learning and development can be integrated into the early grades while
also retaining rigorous standards and expectations for learning i'll now hand this back to speed to
share more about assessments thank you i'll now move on to assessment in tk tk is not required
to use an ongoing whole child assessment i'll provide some context on assessment tools used
in early learning and care programs since tk assessment is under the board's purview
in the california state preschool program programs use the desired results developmental profile or
drdp assessment twice a year this is a developmentally supportive assessment that aligns with
principles from the science of learning for a variety of reasons one reason is that it covers
a breadth of skills not just math and literacy but also looks at expressive and receptive
language and vocabulary social emotional skills and approaches to learning like self-regulation
and executive functioning the longer versions of the drdp tool additionally look at other domains
covered in the preschool learning foundation such as physical development health habits visual and
performing arts science and social science the second reason is that children are not pulled
aside to work one-on-one with a teacher or computer screen instead assessment is integrated
into a child's natural learning environment with a teacher recording observations or prompting the
child to engage in a specific skill skill they want to assess such as counting during a learning
activity the third reason is it's aligned to universal design for learning where children
are able to respond or participate in the assessment in a variety of ways based on their
home language and ability for example when assessing counting a child who is a dual language
learner can say numbers in their home language and a child who has trouble sitting still can
demonstrate the skill by jumping or clapping while they count while results can be calculated to
form a summative score this assessment is primarily used for formative purposes and
to assist teachers in individualizing instruction and overall curriculum planning at the classroom
level this here is an example of the drdp preschool version for one subdomain within math
number sense and quantity this subdomain captures not only the rope counting skills
but children's understanding of quantity and making sense of what number means
to address the developmental continuum of children that could be enrolled in preschool
a wide range of skills are presented in the measure however at age three or the beginning
of preschool children are typically in the exploring later or building earlier domain
and by the end of preschool and transitioning into kindergarten are in building later or integrating
here is an example from the drdp kindergarten tool where you will see the overlap within
the preschool tool in the first three levels again to emphasize that there is a developmental
continuum that is present in kindergarten and different children will fall on different places
on the continuum even if it is below the kindergarten entry expectations the drdp
kindergarten tool has actually been adopted by other states to use as a kindergarten entry
assessment for example the state of illinois has adapted this tool as their mandatory kids
assessment at a kindergarten entry in the domains of math language literacy social emotional and
approaches to learning the drdp is also on several states menu of kindergarten assessments to choose
from we're also aware of some counties in california who have used the drdp kindergarten
tool in their programs the cd is making changes to the drdp to be more inclusive of tk so that
programs may more readily adopt it for example you saw that we have a preschool version and a
kindergarten version but we've heard from teachers that many tk kids either fall on one or the other
depending on their developmental level so we are now combining the tool into one to cover the
broader developmental trajectory that children may be presenting in tk we also plan to add
structured prompts in math and literacy which are essentially direct assessments but still
embedded in a child's learning experience and can be administered in a small group setting
we're also extending the drdp to third grade in the domains of social emotional development
and approaches to learning the hope for this tool is to demonstrate the value of these domains
of development in the early elementary years as referenced in the item currently 29% of lea's
are using the drdp and tk but we hope that this tool becomes more accessible for tk programs
in the future the last thing i'll cover in our assessment section is the lpac requirement
for both tk and kindergarten and english language proficiency assessment type of grade level
standards is federally required for students in public schools within the first 30 days of
enrollment the lpac is based on the kindergarten english language development standards
however as tk is expanded to younger four-year-old children we will need to explore how to implement
the reading and writing sections in a developmentally informed and an effective manner since the
board's purview is over assessments in the lpac we wanted to flag this for you the final aspect
of tk implementation we want to highlight is support for the workforce while the board does
not have authority on workforce requirements or investments that support the workforce
and understanding of the needs and current efforts are important given the essential
role that educators play in tk implementation so tk teachers must meet the requirements
and statute by august 1 2023 and these requirements include holding a number of
credentials one of a number of credentials including a multiple subject credential general
kindergarten primary t3 credential or others and additional expertise in ece or child development
to meet the ece requirement specified in education code section 48 000 g4 teachers can get 24 units
of coursework in early childhood education or child development have professional experience
comparable to those units or have a child development teacher permit or the upcoming
pre-k3 ece specialist credential as of july 1 22 the commission on teaching credentialing
can issue a one-year emergency specialist teaching permit in early childhood education
these emergency specialist teaching permits in ece also called emergency transitional
kindergarten permits assist lea's that are not able to recruit a fully credentialed teacher
for a tk classroom as more children become eligible for tk another aspect of implementation
is a need for additional teachers the learning policy institute has estimated that as many as
20 000 tk teachers will be needed for full implementation in 25 26 which means if lea's
must recruit and hire another 12 to 16 000 teachers in the coming years in addition statute requires
a one to 12 adult to child ratio in tk starting this year and given that tk is a maximum class
size of 24 that means at beginning in this year every classroom needs a second adult
at present that equates to approximately 4 000 additional adults well the full implementation
in 25 26 up to 20 000 staff members will be needed in this role across the state
the upk planning and implementation grant survey asked lea's to report what strategies they are
planning to use to support their local workforce in meeting these requirements districts and charter
schools are already planning a number of efforts to support both prospective and current teachers
in this table found on page 25 of the item i want to highlight that many districts and charter schools
are working in partnership with institutes of higher ed and their county offices of education
to build the pathways for those prospective teachers and to support current teachers in
addition lea's report logistical support is available in many places with advising on
requirements information on scholarships and grant opportunities and in about a quarter of
school districts and charter schools stipends for teacher tuition in addition to the required
qualifications for tk teachers professional learning is an essential part of a quality tk
program teachers leaders and staff will continue to grow as educators particularly in applying the
science of learning and development in their classrooms ensuring that ongoing opportunities
for all involved in tk and early education of coaching resources and mentorship will strengthen
their competencies to understand and meet the developmental needs of diverse learners
areas of focus for professional learning include social emotional learning language and literacy
development and instruction for young children math and science development and instruction
the preschool learning foundations and the use of developmentally informed curriculum
as highlighted previously other areas for professional learning appropriate for tk
educators as well as p3 educators and beyond can include anti-bias teaching mitigating implicit
bias and reducing exclusionary discipline and practices such as suspension trauma-informed
practice healing and restorative practices serving children with disabilities and supporting
multilingual learners this table highlights the percentage of school districts and charter
schools planning to offer professional learning opportunities in their plans or in seven areas
related to developmentally informed practice this the great news is that more than half of
school districts and charters have already included each of these areas in their plans
the strongest responses are for professional learning and literacy and language development
social emotional development with serving children with disabilities and inclusive settings
curriculum selections and implementation and math and science instruction close behind
if you look at table 12 and attachment three of the item you will see a few other topics
for professional learning such as effective adult child interactions supporting multilingual
learners using trauma-informed practices and engaging culturally and linguistically diverse
families which fall under the 50 mark but more than 35 of school districts and charter schools
plan to include them in addition to local efforts by lea's and their partners significant investments
have been made at the state level to to support meeting the demand for qualified teachers and
tk and beyond these investments allow lea's to spend money on teacher and staff recruitment and
hiring as well as offering financial support to parent teachers and opportunities for future
teachers to follow pathways into tk additional investments have been made specifically to
increase availability and accessibility of professional learning for tk and their teachers
such as the upk planning and implementation grant the early education teaching development grant
educator effectiveness block grant the which is administered by the cde and provides
1.5 billion in apportionments through june 26 to support professional learning for teachers
administrators and paraprofessionals who work with students and classified staff that interact with
students to provide accelerated reading support the current year budget allocated 15 million in
one-time funding over three years to support 6 000 teachers and the 20 and the current year
budget also established the golden state pathways program to support lea's to partner with higher
education community groups and employers to promote pathways the commission on teacher
credentialing also has a couple of grants the include the teacher residency grant program
the one-time grants for four-year integrated teacher preparation programs and the california
student aid commission last one i'd like to highlight here is the golden state teacher grant
program an ongoing grant with 100 million in funding per fiscal year between 21 and 26 which
provides up to 20 000 in individual grants to students in ctc approved professional preparation
programs who commit to working in high needs fields such as tk one last investment in the
tk workforce that is important to talk about is the pk3 early childhood specialist specialist
credential which we will discuss in more detail now we'll briefly now the pk3 ece specialist
credential is a specific investment that will support the tk workforce as well as other early
education programs and overall p3 alignment the focus of this credential is the developmentally
supportive practices and instructional strategies to support children from pre-k to third grade
and ensuring that teachers can build the types of quality learning opportunities
and environments that support whole child development build on prior experiences and
integrate children's experiences characteristics assets abilities and needs the credential standards
and teaching performance expectations for the pk3 ece specialist credential were approved at the
october 2022 ctc meeting and the regulations for this credential are currently being developed by
the ctc with the office of administrative law with an anticipated approval in january 23
for closing i'll hand it back to sarah
and we know this has been a really long item very thorough so i will just wrap it up tk and upk are
tremendous achievements and opportunities to provide children in california with positive
learning experience their strengths-based play-based approach to joyful engaged learning
that supports their emotional social cognitive and language development california also has this
opportunity to implement a p3 frame thereby creating greater potential for lasting school
outcomes by adopting the science of learning and development principles and full child approaches
into those early grades and while we didn't have time today we do want to hire two other essential
areas that we will cover in our item more deeply tomorrow at least one of them in special education
the importance of inclusion in the inclusion of children with disabilities in both tk and our
california state preschool program our director of special education mother kelomies will dive
into that a little bit tomorrow in the special ed annual performance report presentation
additionally we really want to emphasize the importance of supporting our multilingual learners
and ensuring that as tk expands so do the supports and programs that foster home language
of multilingual learners along with the english acquisition that is so fun down foundational as we
think about all of our children to create that sense and culture of inclusion and belonging
we also want to acknowledge the governor's 2023-24 proposed budget includes the next year of
funds for tk expansion which means many more children will benefit for tk for years to come
finally we want to celebrate the california's historic investment in upk with utk as the
foundational component is an investment in the future of california it creates a monumental
impact for children who participate their families and their communities supporting children's
development and foundational learning in their early years can increase their success in school
and in life promoting positive health career and social outcomes in adulthood building up
these strengths in children build strengths in their families and their communities and provide
social and economic benefits to society as the whole this concludes our presentation
so i'll hand it back over to our board chair and darling hammon
thank you so much sarah and steven the extraordinary work that you are doing is really
visible across every dimension of tk across a very complicated mixed delivery system
bringing coherence and thoughtfulness to all of these elements with multiple agencies including
cde and the ctc dss etc so we're we're very grateful to you for all of this effort we're
going to go to the public comments slide and get the public comment queuing up right now those who'd
like to call in can use the telephone number and the access code provided on the slide that is
shown now i'd like to remind everyone of the framing comments i made at the beginning of this
item and the state board's you know particular limited authority in this space and while we're
waiting i want to ask our member patil broncette if she would like to kick us off with some comments
thank you so i also just want to join our board president in thanking sarah and steven and also
superintendent thurman for not only an incredible presentation but for incredible leadership and
tenacity in rolling out what is an entirely new grade in california which has not been
done in a couple of hundred years so it is a historic moment and and one that has required
an incredible amount of labor but i think it has been a labor of love so i'm just incredibly
appreciative of the work that cd has undertaken in order to actually move this forward i also
just wanted to reflect on on an earlier comment that our board president mentioned about the
scale of this program this will be the largest pre-k program for four-year-olds in the country
and also just even to put it in the broader context of the multiple investments that the
governor has made on the early side of early learning inclusive of the state preschool program
and child care at full implementation california will be overseeing more early learning early care
and learning seats in california than the entire of the federal government's investments in head
start across all 50 states so it is an epic undertaking and it is i think incredibly exciting
and and just want to salute the work that is being done across the multiple agencies to make that
happen it is also i think equally important to recognize that it's it's not just a scale
undertaking many of the impacts that sarah talked through in terms of school records
terms of academic social emotional learning are all incredibly
and the the data point that always i think stays with me is from getting down to facts around this
idea that even though california's school districts are actually beating national averages already
in terms of annual growth for the k-12 students because so many kids in california start in third
grade almost a full academic year behind the catch-up is very very difficult and so the early
learning investment i think that is being brought forward with utk is really a incredibly important
strategy for making sure that all of that good work that's done in the later years does not have
to be catch-up but can just be progress which is obviously i think what what all kids and families
and supporters of public education want the last thing i'll just say is that i think across a number
of the points in the powerpoint sarah and and steven both mentioned that this is a p to three
frame and so this is work that connects not just for the year of utk but has implications
relation and for ongoing work and coordination with three trajectories so that is super exciting
i keep thinking of kamala harris saying that she was it was she was the first but not the last
and i i think this will be the first sort of moment of thinking for so many school districts
about how to work with early learning but it certainly will not be the last and there's lots
of exciting work ahead so thank you guys again thank you i think unless there are there any
clarifying questions that need to be asked now and then we'll get to go to public comment and
come back for discussion vice president glover woods thank you i have just a quick clarifying
question is the lpac currently administered to our tk students
yes it is okay thank you sarah thank you right and that question will be in front of us as we
get to younger and younger four-year-olds okay i see no other hands at the moment so let's go
to public comment if there is some uh yes we do have one caller in the queue i will open the
phone line now okay afternoon please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time starts now uh good afternoon jessica saco on behalf of children now we applaud
the progress the state is making towards offering upk to all four-year-olds we are pleased the board
has made space in its package agenda to receive an update and provide their perspectives on this
important education initiative i applaud deputy superintendent sarah neville morgan and her team
for the deliberate framing of the work before us as universal pre-k made up of transitional
kindergarten csp head start expanded learning and private preschool providers and full recognition
of the unique early learning and care needs of young children and their families progress to
date is significant and there are still several implementation issues to be addressed which we
describe in our letter i draw your attention to the role the state board and department can
take in supporting and retaining the existing teacher workforce through promoting the utilization
of educator effectiveness funds to support teachers in improving and growing their craft
as younger children enter tk classrooms similarly the content and curriculum for tk classrooms must
evolve to meet the developmental and educational needs of children as young as 48 months who will
become tk students by 2526 thank you for your time thank you okay that concludes public comment
for item number 10 thank you very much both for that amazing presentation and the thoughtful
public comment and now is their board discussion i remind you this is an information item it's
going to set the table for the work that we may need to do in the future but there's no decisions
today any comments or questions
member mccullin and then vice president glover woods yes thank you thank you for this item
it's really exciting where you can capture additional children to have a preschool
experience those that might be missing i'm so happy that we included head starts too and in
the discussion and coordination i have a question on is there any type of recommended number of
minutes or time for the pk programs thank you
sarah steven
how are you thinking about the time frame there's rank there's required minutes
as part of tk so i think it's 180 instructional minutes but i'm getting confirmation on that
yeah and then of course the way that it's framed is to be incorporated in
to the extent possible full day program do you want to speak to that sarah as well yeah so it's
180 instructional minutes or 36 000 minutes a year and that's within as you look at the expanded
learning opportunities program the nine hours of programming if families so choose so that if the
tk program is part day or school day you can still have some hours of the expanded learning
program coming around that or in some cases they're using the california state preschool
program or even head start to partner with for those so just to the layers of complexity
there are part day and full day programs and then extended day wraparounds that are all being
coordinated anything else okay member glover woods and then member yeshimoto tari and then
member rodriguez thank you um steven and sarah thank you so much for such a comprehensive
presentation and a comprehensive board item it's just very refreshing to be able to have
conversation about what's happening with our our littles if you will and how critical that is to
all of the other things we look at with grad rate and ele and math proficiency that foundation
really starts with our our youngest learners and what we do to support them so i more this is more
of a comment not a question at all but just to emphasize a statement that was in our board item
which was that as we're thinking about transitional kindergarten and the curriculum and the practices
that it's really about looking at taking those practices and pushing them up through k and through
three as opposed to taking those education the elementary practices let's say in first and second
grade and pushing them down it's going to be really critical um it's already been critical for
transitional kindergarten because we've had that grade for for a little bit of time as we saw in
the timeline but even as we expand it now to younger four-year-olds it's going to be critical
that the curriculum and assessment is not kindergarten light but that it is actually
developmentally appropriate for children coming in at that age and to set them up for success so
thank you again for your presentation and i look forward to more conversation on this topic
thank you so much um i think next is member yoshimoto tori then member rodriguez and then member
oaken uh that was so articulately said vice president glover woods i i'm not going to repeat
that uh in my own words because uh that was that's part of my concern this is a proud moment
it's very very exciting uh and i would extend you know to connect with what you said of my
wondering i suppose about the bridge between you know mixed delivery upk
including transitional kindergarten but also being under the tk being under the purview of the sve
just to the conversations around uh state frameworks coming up in the future which
have connections to state adoptions for k-8 and wondering how we might be able to
uh really have a seamless bridge you know particular in the mixed delivery model so that
we're ensuring that there are developmentally supportive and appropriate expectations for our
tk students but also for students that are in other programs in the mixed delivery model who
will be joining their peers in the second year of kindergarten and elementary school
and so i look forward to that conversation which doesn't need a necessarily a response today
um particularly around the um the curriculum and you know the adoption pieces
and then secondly and maybe this connects with the conversation tomorrow um
so maybe a comment and not necessarily a question at this point but i noticed in the
a supporting documentation that uh first was excited to see that for the state preschools
contracting agencies that the set-aside amount for students with disabilities
is increasing in the coming years um each year just a little bit more through 2024-25
and that we expect that to increase um the percentages of three or four-year-old students
since in state preschool with iups but that also that we didn't have the data on
how many students in our state preschools were having that inclusive experience yet and so i was
wondering about what are like what the next steps are to be able to capture that data or maybe
perhaps what the barriers are that need to be problem solved and i'm happy to wait until
tomorrow if that's more appropriate i'll do just a tiny response and then we can capture it a
little bit more over there so first about the preschool learning foundations we so agree and
it was wonderful to hear that they are required for use in our california state preschool program
and a lot i would say probably in california all of the head starts also use the preschool
learning foundations as well and then a lot of our title 22 sort of private pk programs also
access them we make those freely available so there is much more expanded use of those
across the state um so we'll see greater and greater alignment and then as we look at our
littles with disabilities and including them one of the things that happened in this current year
so sort of last year's budget cycle is um better data collection and so not only will are there
requirements around pulling out tk as a separate indicator and grade basically to follow that but
there are some around california state preschool program and our lea's where we will get the student
identifier and that will also help us understand a little bit more about the children so that is
something we continue to look at within cde as we look at what we call results count and wanting
to use data to then inform our practice and how we're supporting our programs more thank you thank
you so much member rodriguez um yes i have so much to say and i'm filled with excitement but i'm just
going to keep it at my uh hats off my applause to everyone who has um gotten this initiative
this far it's been a lot of work i remember um during governor newsom's first election he
talked about how important it is to close that achievement gap in zero to three and um you know
and seeing this uh come to fruition just fills me with joy so thank you thank you to everyone
at every level terrific member alken
i just want to echo the excitement um and also um you know i was struck by there was a slide about
developmentally supportive curriculum and there was sort of a list of things that um a classroom
should include or the curriculum should include that was developmentally appropriate and it was
small groups rather than direct instruction and um there's a whole list and um what i noted was
those are all the same things that i think are developmentally appropriate at the high school
level or the middle school level um because they're so informed by the science of learning
and development and um so the thing one of the things i'm most excited for and this is maybe a
little um just based on the context in which um i've worked professionally is the ways in which
the science of learning and development are driving the the the way we're in the way we're
building the program the way the credentialing is going to be established the thinking around
classrooms the thinking about curriculum and that that's not just tk but making its way up
through third grade and hopefully really impacting the rest of our tk tk through 12 program as well
and i just think that's a huge hugely exciting development for the state of california that we
have this opportunity to um have the science of development be at the starting place of our
program plan rather than commit working backwards and trying to figure out how to fix what we've
inherited and was not planned around the way young people learn um all this time so yay thank you
thank you member patilla bronson i just was prompted in hearing both sharon
and allison's comments about the curriculum frameworks um to just flag that there are
opportunities i think ahead to think about how how to incorporate um things from the preschool
learning foundation more explicitly um the power of those frameworks oftentimes moves mountains
and publishers and wanting to to sort of take that up in the future around how to make that
more explicit and make the alignment not just legislative intent language but more more explicit
and seamless yeah i noticed when we were when sarah and steven were talking about the curriculum
and the nature of developmentally appropriate practice how many people had smiles on their faces
so it is something that you know we want to build on throughout the grades well this is an
inspiring and informative session it is an informational session we will have other decisions
down the road we really appreciate it you gave us a wonderful inspiring end to our first board day
and with that seeing no further discussion i want to thank sarah i want to thank steven all of the
staff at cde who have been involved with this and in the other agencies who have been collaborating
and our state board staff as well who have really helped to facilitate some of the actions that were
needed to start this program off on such a good foot tomorrow we will meet in close session to
discuss and or take action on the following legal matters mark s versus state and napa valley
unified school district versus sb e i hereby continue the meeting and end today's session
at 3 14 pm wow go party and look forward to seeing you tomorrow